WELL. WHEN WE GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED- WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE'VE GOT. MEMBERS
OF BOTH PARTIES IN- FOLKS WILL
BE ABLE TO MAKE THEIR WAY OVER
HERE I KNOW THAT ENERGY
COMMITTEES MEETING THIS MORNING
AS WELL SO I KNOW THAT. HAS
CAUSED SOME OVERLAP. DODD WE'VE
GOT ONE ITEM ON THE DOCKET THAT
IS SB THREE SEVENTY TWO WE
WELCOME EVERYONE BACK HAPPY NEW
YEAR. HIWELCOME TO WHAT WILL
BE A REFER AN EXCITING YEAR OF.
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY POSSIBLE
ASK THE- THE AUTHOR CINEMA
CASKEY TO PRESENT SB THREE
SEVEN TWO. AND YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY OR SHOULD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO DO IS START OFF WITH A
LITTLE SLIDE SHOW ON THE ORGAN
BOTTLE- BILL I WAS I DIDN'T AND
JUST FOR SENATE DIE WE'VE
BECAUSE IS THE ONLY MEASURE ON
THE BALLOT BECAUSE IT'S THIS
AND CONCEPTUAL ISSUES INVOLVED
HERE WE'VE HAD. EXTENDED THE
CENTER OF COURTESY OF A LITTLE
MORE TIME THAT WOULD TYPICALLY
BE ALLOWED IN THE PRESENTATION
OF A BILL OF THE SNOW AND ON
OUR DOCKET TODAY AND MISTER
CHAIR YOU MAY BE AWARE THE
CENTER DOLLY LIVES TO STONE'S
THROW AWAY FROM THE OREGON
BORDER SO HE'S FAMILIAR WITH
RIDE HAILING FROM THROWING
STONE GROWS GROCERIES. AND THEN
IN THIS BAILEY PUT TOGETHER
THIS THIS LIGHT SHOW HE'S A
FORMER MEMBER OF THE AT THE
ORGAN LEGISLATURE WHO IS NOW
BEEN HIRED BY THIS PRIVATE
CONSORTIUM OR COOPERATIVES THEY
CALL IT IN IN OREGON TO RUN
THEIR STUPID **** STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM SO- FIRST LIGHT. OR WE
HAVE A LITTLE VIDEO HERE THAT
THEY PUT TOGETHER I THINK IT'S
A THIRTY A. SIXTY SECOND DD IF
WE COULD HIT THE NEXT SLIDE. I
ACTION LOCAL BOTTLE DRIVES. A
BUSTLING WITH PEOPLE ON EARTH
DAY BUT THE HOLIDAY ISN'T
NECESSARILY THE REASON WHY. IT
INCREASE IN RATES ANSON ADDED
CONVENIENCE AND PEOPLE SIGNING
UP FOR THE PROGRAM INTRO. HE'S
EVER DONE GETTING MONEY BACK
FOR HER BOTTLES FOR THE FIRST
TIME LET'S LIKE GET THAT STUFF
OUT OF THE WAY AND YOU KNOW GET
SOME CASH WITH AS WELL SHE'S
ONE OF THE TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
WHO ARE OPENING UP AN ACCOUNT
WITH THE PROGRAM EVERY DAY. FOR
SOMEONE AS BUSY AS I AM IT'S
GREAT TO HAVE THE BACKS BAGS
YOU KNOW JUST CONFIRMING YOUR
CAR TAX THEM UP AND DROPPING
OFF AND NEXT THING YOU KNOW IT
YOU'LL END UP WITH SOME CASH BY
THE END OF THE DAY. FEEL
STRAINING IS WITH OREGON
BEVERAGE WE CLING COOPERATIVE
WHICH OPERATES THE PROGRAM
WE'RE VERY BUSY- WHICH IS
EXCITING I'LL DROP IS SEEN A
MAJOR BOOST IN RETURNS FROM 65%
BEFORE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO NOW
ABOUT 85% EACH MONTH. THE
REASON IN EIGHT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN RATES WENT FROM FIVE
TO TEN CENTS FOR EACH BOTTLE
MORE CONTAINERS ARE COMING BACK
FOR PEOPLE RETURNING- IN THEIR.
DEPOSITS AND ALL THOSE
CONTAINERS ARE GETTING RECYCLED.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS A STORAGE
CHARGES A TEN CENT DEPOSIT ON
THESE BOTTLES AND CANS. AND
THEN YOU AS A CONSUMER CAN
BRING THEM BACK FOR CASH. THE
GREEN BAG DROP OFF AND AN APP
HAS ADDED TO THE CONVENIENCE.
OF THIS DRAMA. AND USE THAT TO.
JUST REGISTER FOR AN ACCOUNT AT
YOUR NEAREST BOTTLE DROP CENTER
AND PICK UP YOUR CARD IN BAGS.
ACTIVATED ONLINE AND START
FILLING THOSE BAGS THEN DROP IT
OFF AND CASH OUT THERE'S A LOT
HAPPENING IN RECYCLING IN THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW. AND THE RETURN
RATES- IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
HOW ORGAN CONTINUES TO BE A
LEADER AND- ENVIRONMENTAL AND
CONSERVATION ISSUES. NOW SOME
USE THAT CASH BACK FOR THEIR
SAVINGS MAYBE FOR A LITTLE
EXTRA SPENDING MONEY BUT YOU
CAN ALSO USE IT TO GIVE BACK TO
LOCAL CHARITIES USING THAT AB.
PRETTY FOLDERS KGW NEWS. AND
THAT'S THE STORY FROM OREGON SO
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE THIS
IS A BRIEF HISTORY OF WHAT'S OF
WHAT'S HAPPENED I KNOW WE LIKE
WE THINK THE CALIFORNIA'S THE
CENTER OF THE UNIVERSE AND
WE'VE GOT THE BEST. RECYCLING
PROGRAM THAT STARTED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX BUT FIFTEEN
YEARS. BEFORE ON EARTH THEY ARE
FOLLOWING EARTH DAY ORGANS.
SIGNED THE- THEIR BOTTLE BILL
AND THEY BASICALLY BEING BEEN
RUNNING THEIR PROGRAM FOR
TWELVE YEARS THIS IS THEIR
THERE THEY'RE COMING AT LEAST
THE CREATION OF IT. AND WHAT
I'D LIKE YOU TO. LOOK AT IS THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOW A PROGRAM
WHERE THEY HAVE REUSABLE
BOTTLES WE'LL GET ANOTHER SLIDE
LATER AND THAT THAT INCREASE IN
THE DEPOSIT. TO TEN CENTS HAS
BEEN A GAME CHANGER BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT JUST. TRASH AND AN
INCIDENTAL THING TEN CENSUS
REAL MONEY AND THAT COMBINATION
IN THE LAST. THREE YEARS OF THE
REUSABLE BOTTLES THIS IS. THINK
OF YOUR CRAFT BREWERIES AND
WINE PEOPLE ARE IN THIS- THIS
EXPANSION INTO TEN SENSIBLE
REALLY HAS HAS ALLOWED THESE
DISTRIBUTORS WHO RUN THE WHOLE
SHOW UP IN OREGON. TO REALLY
RUN A FIRST RATE PROGRAM THAT
pIS THIS IS THE SOME STATISTICS
AND REFRESH YOUR MEMORY ORGAN
HAS ABOUT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA HAS FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE NOT THAT EACH OF THESE
NUMBERS SHOULD HAVE. A ZERO ONE
EFFORT BUT FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION YOU KNOW WHEN WE
LOOK AT. FIVE THOUSAND ORGAN
EMPLOYEES PROBABLY AROUND FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA EMPLOYEES
ABOUT YOU KNOW FIVE PROCESSING
PLANTS DEPENDING ON DIE
DYNAMICS ABOUT FIFTY WERE WERE
THEY GET WERE YOU SEE THIS WERE
ALL. THE CANS AND- BOTTLES AND
THE- PLASTICS COME IN AND THEY
GET SUPER SQUISH ONCE THEY'VE
BEEN THE BARCODES BEEN READ
PEOPLE GOT THEIR MONEY AND- AND
THE LIKE. AND AGAIN THEY'RE
PROCESSING YOU KNOW A TWO
BILLION CONTAINERS A YEAR I
WOULD PROBABLY YOU KNOW NORTH
OF TWENTY BILLION EASILY EASILY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA I'M WHAT THE
WHAT THE POTENTIAL TO AND- THE
LAST FLIGHT FOR. FROM NOT ONLY
THE- LIBERALS AND THE
CONSERVATIVES ON THE COMMITTEE
BUT ZERO TAX DOLLARS SPENT
THAT'S THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF
THIS THING IS THAT WE'RE FIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO SAY. HERE'S A
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAS
BEEN YOU KNOW GOT BANDAIDS ON
PALM BANDES PEN BANDAIDS WE
KNOW WHAT'S NOT WORKING I'LL
GET TO THAT MY PRESENTATION BUT
HERE IS HERE IS LET PRIVATE
INDUSTRY RUN THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON WILL GIVE THEM THE LEAD
TIME. AND THEY CAN LEARN FROM
WHAT TH THEN THE PREVIOUS CHART
ON WHAT WHAT OREGON HAS DONE
AND WE'RE GOING TO DO WITH
BIGGER. AND BETTER BECAUSE
WE'RE CALIFORNIA NEXT SLIDE.
THE WAY THAT THIS. COOPERATIVE
IS DONE THEY'VE ACTUALLY BY THE
SITES THEY ACTUALLY BY THE
SITES THEY OWN THE LAND THEY
MAKE THE INVESTMENT BECAUSE
THIS IS PRIVATE PRIVATE COMPANY
COMPANIES AND THIS IS THE
BOTTLE DROP WHICH IS THE BIG
ENCHILADA THIS IS GOT A PERSON
WHO'S IN THERE WHO'S LIKE
CUSTOMER SERVICE THAT HELPS
PEOPLE WHEN THEY WHEN THEY DO
THE DROPS THEY HAVE PEOPLE IN
THE BACK THAT. SORTING THAT TO
GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE. THIS IS
WHAT THIS IS WHAT LOOK THIS IS
THE REDEMPTION CENTERS HAVE
EVERYTHING THAT'S THE MACHINE
THAT YOU SAW ON THE VIDEO WHERE
PEOPLE COME IN WITH ALL THEIR
BAGS AND THEY FEED A MAN. AT
THE FEET OF MEANT THEY ALSO
HAVE. AN ACCOUNT SOME AND IF
YOU GO BEHIND THERE YOU KNOW
THEY GOT THAT MECHANISM THAT
SEPARATES CLASS SEPARATE.
SEPARATE PLASTIC SEPARATES-
WITH THE OTHER ONE PLASTIC
GLASS. ALUMINUM ALUMINUM AND
THEN AND THEN THEY CAN ACTUALLY
SEPARATE THEM BY COLORS RIGHT.
THE IN THIS. WHEN YOU LOOK AT A
BAIL OF GREEN PLASTIC AND A
BALE OF CLEAR PLASTIC. IT'S THE
SMELL OF MONEY MAN IT'S AT THAT
SEPARATION CREATES THE VALUE
BECAUSE YOU'RE GETTING THE
BEST. BEST FITS SO THEY CAN YOU
KNOW FOR OUR PURPOSES HERE
THEY'VE GOT TWENTY FIVE OF
THESE FULL SERVICE REDEMPTION
CENTERS WHERE YOU CAN GO WHEN
THERE'S A PERSON THEY'RE
THEY'RE HELPING YOU. AND THEY
HAVE THAT THAT KOSKS- ALSO THE
LITTLE THAT THEY YES IT WILL BE
IN THE NEXT LIKE BUT ONCE AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR. MISTER I CENTER
DOLLY ZERO COST TAXPAYERS YOU
KNOW THIS IS THIS IS THE FUTURE
THIS IS A PRIVATE INDUSTRY.
GOVERNMENT SAYING YOU GUYS RUN
IT YOU'RE THE BEST THAT NEXT
SLIDE. OKAY SO WITH WHAT'S THE
GREEN BAG ACCOUNTS AT THIS IS
THEY DEVELOP THIS AND YOU CAN
USE ALL ON THE- ON THE SECOND
SLIDE. YOU TAKE ALL YOUR
BOTTLES AND YOU PUT THEM CLICK
CANCEL YOU PUT THEM TOGETHER
AND YOU SIGN UP FOR THE PROGRAM
YOU REGISTER IN THE A. C. THIS
GAL IT'S GOT THE LITTLE CARD
YOU COULD THEY'VE GOT THOSE
THINGS YOU PUT ON YOUR KEY
CHAIN. WE GOT THE APP AND YOU
YOU YOU WALK UP AND YOU YOU GO.
YOU GET A NUMBER YOU GET AN
ACCOUNT AND YOU SIMPLY. GET
YOUR- BAR CODES INFORMATION YOU
BACK IT YOU. TURN IT UP AND YOU
DROP IT OFF AT A ADDED CHAOS IN
AT ONE OF THESE DROPS AND THEY
HAVE THESE DROPS ALL OVER THE
BEAUTY OF THIS. THE BEAUTY OF
THIS IS THAT THEY CAN GO INTO
RURAL AREAS THEY CAN GOING SUB
AREAS THEY CAN GO THE URBAN
AREAS AND THEY'RE FINDING THE
PEOPLE WILL PUT BAGS IN. AND
IT'S BACK TO YOU GET ON YOUR
COMPUTER YOU DO WHAT. ALSO HALF
OF. CALIFORNIA ARE. OUR COOPER
IF THEY GET UP CAN LEARN FROM
THEM THEY HAVE A BLUE BAG
PROGRAM. AND THE BLUE BRAG
PROGRAM IS FOR SCHOOLS AND
NONPROFITS SO IF YOU WANT TO
GIVE IF YOU WANT TO SIGN UP
FROM YOUR ACCOUNT. AND HAVE A
GO AUTOMATICALLY TO YOUR-
NONPROFIT OF THE OF AB OF
CHOICE HE'S PUT IN THE BLUE
BACK THIS IS IT THE NAME BOTTLE
DROP IS THAT IT THAT'S IT
THAT'S A STATE. ENTITY THAT THE
STATE I KNOW WHAT'S THIS
PRIVATE COOPERATIVE IT BUT IT'S
THE NAME OF THE BRAND THAT THEY
HAVE. BEEN WHO IT. COMPANY OR
IS IT- IT'S ACOOPERATIVE IS
COOPER IS QUITE THIS PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP. NO
PRIVATE- IT'S WITH BASS WHAT'S
BEEN CREATED BY THAT ISRAEL
DOESN'T WATERS OF SAID WE'RE
GONNA CALL CALIFORNIA MAY CALL
THE BOTTLE FINDER. COLLEGES AND
SEE. THE MAYBE THEY THEY ARE
THEY ARE. THAT THE- B. R. C. IS
A- RIGHT THE ORGAN BEVERAGE
RECYCLING COOPERATIVE THERE THE
PRIVATE INDUSTRY THAT'S RUNNING
AT THAT WITH THE DISTRIBUTOR
AND THIS IS AN ENTITY CREATED
BY THE OF YOUR SEAT LIKE THIS
IS THE- THIS IS THE- PHYSICAL
ASSETS THAT THEY HAVE WHAT THEY
HOW. HOW THEY THEIR MARKETING
THEIR BRAND OKAY SAY K. IT'S
THE BOTTLE DROP YOU GO NGUYEN
INTO PROJECT AND I WAS WHEN I
WAS HERE YOU KNOW THE- I
THINK. UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF.
MUNICIPALITIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
THINK THAT THESE RECYCLING
CENTERS ARE YOU KNOW- AWAY WORD
FOR FIRST PLACE FOR HOMELESS
PEOPLE NOW THAT IT'S ONLY YOU
GET YOU HAVE A CONVENIENCE ON
OUTSIDE YOUR GROCERY STORE JUST
GONNA HAVE HOMELESS PEOPLE WHAT
SHOPPING CARTS. HANGING AROUND.
THIS WAS LIKE. AFTER CHURCH IT
WAS UNBELIEVABLE I WAS THERE ON
A WEDNESDAY AFTERNOON AT OUR
WEDNESDAY MORNING AT TEN. AND
ALL KINDS OF NORMAL PEOPLE
PULLING UP THEIR CARS GOING IN
YOU KNOW CHATTING IT UP AND
DROPPING. DROPPING THE STEPS
OFF AND IT WAS CONVENIENT YOU
KNOW I TALKED TO A COUPLE OF
FROM SAID. THE BILL CC I GOTTA
GET TO WORK BUT HE GET ON MY
WAY. NEXT SLIDE. SO THIS IS
THE- THIS I THE- I GUESS. WHAT
A NOTHER SIZE. EXPRESS TO GET
THE BALL CHOP EXPRESS SO THIS
IS NOT THE FULL MONTY WE HAVE.
YOU CAN GO IN AND YOU CAN. DROP
OFF YOUR BOTTLES ONE BY ONE
THIS IS ONLY FOR THE GREEN BACK
IN A BLUE BACKDROP. AND YOU SEE
THEY HAVE A TIME SO THAT THEY
DON'T WANT PEOPLE LOITERING
AROUND THERE. BUT YOU CAN
YOU'VE GOT YOUR CARD USE. YOU
SWIPE IT. YOU OPEN IT UP AND
YOU DROP IT AND YOU'RE GONNA
SIT THIS IS WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THE RURAL PEOPLE. AND THE P. IT
LOVE THIS BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY
ARE BEING SERVED WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR SOME OF THE PEOPLE. AND WE
WILL HELP. HEARING ABOUT ALL
THE TIMES THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
BEING SERVED IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND WHAT DO THESE
THINGS IS AN EASY DROP IN AT.
THIS AND PRIVATE BUSINESS THE
SIDES BE SOMEWHAT THE MAP IS.
IT LOOKS SIMILAR TO THIS. IN
THE- IN THE CITIES IN AN URBAN
AREA. IT SAYS IT'S NOT EXACTLY
AS THEY PUT IT WITHIN A STORE
BUT IT'S AT THIS PLACE WHERE
YOU COME IN. THE BACK AND- AND-
AND GET OUT OF TOUCH. I'M SO
THAT'S EXPRESS NESS. NEXT ONE.
OKAY SAID THIS IS THE- THIS IS.
WHAT I WOULD GUESS SO I CALL IT
THE- THE- FULL MONTY LIKE SO
THIS IS GOT THE BOTTLE SHOP YOU
SEE ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE.
THIS IS AN OUTDOOR FACILITY BUT
ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE IT'S GOT
TO WITH THOSE LITTLEVENDING
MACHINES REVERSE VENDING
MACHINES. THAT YOU'RE WHEN YOU
WALK IN AND IF YOU WANTED TO.
YOU WANT TO DO THAT YOU CAN
REVERSE SPEND IT AND THERE'S-
AND THEN THE OTHER THE GREEN.
THE OTHER SIDE HE'S GOT THE-
THE BACKDROP SO YOU'VE GOT
THAT. YOU YOU CAN GO IN AND YOU
CAN DROP IT OFF IN THERE. THIS
IS WHAT I THINK OF YOU KNOW.
SUBURBIA YOU KNOW WHERE OR-
SMALL MARKETS WHERE YOU WANT TO
HAVE THE CONVENIENCE EVERYBODY
AND IT'S NOT US IT'S NOT CAL
RECYCLES NOT TO SIGN THIS. THE
LOGISTICS THAT THE SAYING THIS
THIS IS COULD BE PROUD
INDUSTRY. WHAT MAKES SENSE TO
SERVICE THE EERIE BECAUSE-
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE FULL
RESPONSE. OF IT. YOU SEE THAT
LITTLE KIOSK ON THE RIGHT THAT
THAT LITTLE MACHINE THEY GOT.
ALL OVER THAT GOT THAT AT FRED
MEYER SAFE WAY COSCO. AT THE
ALL THE ALL THE- SERVICE
CENTERS AND THAT'S WHERE YOU GO
IN WITH THE- MUSIC THEY SAID
THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE A DAY ARE
SIGNING UP FOR THE THING. YOU
GO WHEN THEY'RE YOU PUTTING
YOUR NAME YOU GET AN ACCOUNT
NUMBER IN AND- IT SPITS OUT THE-
YOUR TAX AT YOUR- YOUR CODE YOU
BARCODE SO THAT. WHEN YOU TAKE
A GREEN BAG AND YOU DROP IT
OFF. IT'S IN THERE. YOU CAN
ALSO GO IN. IN THERE AND- THAT
WILL TELL YOU WHAT THE UPDATE
IS HOW MUCH MONEY YOU HAVE IN
YOUR ACCOUNT. THAT THAT YOU
COULD USE AND THEN THEY HAVE
LIKE A- THE CASH MACHINES IF
YOU WANT TO GET CASH TO SOME
PEOPLE WANT TO GET CASH. AND
SOME PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO CASH
IN AGAIN. YOU KNOW. THEY GOT
THEIR COMMITTED TO EIGHTY OF
THESE LOCATIONS YOU CAN IMAGINE
CALIFORNIA PUT A ZERO ON IT AND
THAT'S WHERE. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT IT BUT IT'S
EASY IT'S FASTER IT'S CLEAN AND
EVERYBODY'S ALL IN. NEXT SLIDE.
OKAY SO YOU GET YOUR CASH TO
THIS IS. THIS IS THE WAY THAT
WE TEACH. YOU KNOW IT IT'S ONE
OF THE WAYS WE TEACH KIDS ABOUT
THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND THE
BENEFITS OF RECYCLING. BUT ALSO
THE VALUE OF MONEY. AN WHAT
THEY'VE COME UP WITH THE CAN
THEIR PROGRAM HAS MATURED. OUR
NEW COOPERATIVE WILL BE ABLE TO
TAKE ALL THE GOOD THINGS BUT-
WHAT. WHAT WE'RE FINALLY
FINDING IS AT THE RETAIL STORE
SHOULD ON THE ONES THAT DON'T.
THEY HAVE TO. PAY A HUNDRED
BUCKS IF THEY DON'T HAVE A
CONVENIENCE OWN AND THE ONES
THAT HAVE THE CLEAN SOUNDS.
THEY'RE OFFERING THESE TWENTY
PERCENT. REWARDS AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY PUTTING THESE CHAOS I
WAS AT A FRED MEYER TO CHAOS.
IS RIGHT THERE FRED MEYERS
EIGHT IN THE TO DO WHAT THEY
HAD ONE OF THOSE. GREEN
BACKDROPS. BUT THEY'RE SAYING.
IF YOU COME IN WITH YOUR
LITTLE. RECEIPT THAT I HAVE
EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS. ON MY- ON
MY ACCOUNT BECAUSE WE'VE
RECYCLED- SO MUCH. THEY'LL GIVE
YOU A 20% REWARD. IN PART OF IT
IS FROM THE YOU KNOW THE-
AMAZON WHERE PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING INTO STORES ANYMORE SO
THAT. BRICK AND MORTAR FOLKS
WANT THEM TO GO TO STORES THEY
GOT A GREAT PROGRAM. TO SAVE
FOR COLLEGE SO AGAIN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU TELL YOUR
KIDS WHEN THEY RECYCLE. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA PUT THIS IN YOUR
COLLEGE ACCOUNT IT DEPENDS ON
THE FAMILY MAN IT'S JUST. I'M
JUST SAYING THAT YOU CAN GIVE
THAT. YOU CAN. GET MORE MONEY
FOR YOURSELF GOING TO THIS. YOU
JUST GO IN THERE AND SAY GIVE
ME THE CASH. AND THE FINDING
MORE MORE PEOPLE LIKE THAT THE
LAST THREE NEXT LIFE. OKAY SO
THIS IS HOW THE MEASURE SUCCESS
AND I DON'T YOU KNOW THESE
LITTLE DOTS ON THE BOTTOM ARE
ALL THE LITTLE POINTS SEE IF
AND IN. THE CITY WHEN YOU GOT
THE ON THE TOP SLIDES GOT THE
DIFFERENT POINTS WITH A WERE
YOU CAN. OR SIGNING UP
OBVIOUSLY IN THE URBAN AREAS
THERE'S MORE THAN THE- THAN
THE- RURAL AREAS BUT THE BIG
PICTURE IN OREGON IS THAT YOU
SEE COVERED. YEAH DROP OFFICERS
ON THE SECOND ONE THEY'RE ALL
DROP OFF CENTER SO THEY'VE GOT
IT COVERED SO YOU WOULD
IMAGINE. IN A COUPLE OF YEARS
WHEN THIS PROGRAM IS UP AND
RUNNING THAT'S THE SAME THING
IS GOING TO HAPPEN IN
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE GOING TO.
THEY'RE GOING TO. THEY'RE GOING
TO DOTHAT AND- YOU KNOW AGAIN
THE NONPROFITS IS YOU KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT THE
NONPROFITS BUT THEY THEY GOT A
BILLION BUCKS AT THAT FOLKS ARE
GIVING ON THE- ON THE BLUE
BAGS- BUT THE OTHER. THE OTHER.
INFORMATION AND WHAT YOU HAVE
IS IT SIXTY FOUR THESE
REDUCTIONS ARE COMING TO THE
BALL DROP SO. IT'S POPULAR IT'S
IT THE- THE OREGONIANS ARE. ARE
EMBRACING THIS- COOPERATIVE.
SUCCESS THAT THEY HAVE IN. AS
HE WE CAN SEE ONCE AGAIN ON THE
BOTTOM INFORMATION. ZERO TAX
DOLLARS SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
NO MORE NO MORE. CONCERNS ABOUT
HOW CAL RECYCLES END OF IT IN
ADDITION IT'S NOT GOING TO COST
THE TAXPAYERS ANY MONEY TO HAVE
THIS SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTED IN CALIFORNIA NEXT
SLIDE. OKAY SO WHERE IS WHICH
REAL GO BECAUSE WE'VE HAD YOU
KNOW I'VE HAD DIFFERENT BILLS
ON CONTENT WE'VE HAVE OTHER BUT
THE CHAIR HAS HAS A BILL WE'RE
TRYING TO SEE WE'RE HOW DO WE
GET CALIFORNIANS MATERIAL TO BE
RECYCLED HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
I SAY LOOK NORTH. LOOK NORTH
BECAUSE A 100% OF PLASTIC AND
100% A GLASS IS BEING RECYCLED
IN OREGON. AND EVEN THE AND
THAT INCLUDES A REFILLING THIS
NEW HOT BOTTLES AND THE OLD
ALUMINIUM IS IN DOMESTIC SO
WE'RE NOT THIS THE CHINA
SUPPORT THE NATIONAL SORT AND
ALL THESE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
DAY IN THE COTTON AND TAKE OUR
STUFF IN THE CONTAMINATION OF
WE HAVE WE CLEAN UP OUR- OUR
RECYCLING PROGRAM AND- IT'S-
ALL. IN CALIFORNIA. EXCELLENT.
OKAY SO WE NEED TO THINK WHAT
THE AGAIN GO BACK. THE RECYCLE
PLASTIC IN OREGON NO NO ARE THE
ARE REALLY COULD DO WONDERS
POINT ONCE WE VOTE ON THREE
SEVEN TWO AND IT BECOMES LAW
OKAY THAT'S WHAT I MEANT I WAS
GETTING A LITTLE EXCITED THERE
RESEARCHER OKAY SO WHAT'S A NEW
THING THAT THIS THAT THIS.
PRIVATE PROPERTY NOT GOVERNMENT.
WHETHER IT'S AN OLD IT'S A GOOD
IDEA IS RE USABLE. BOTTLES AND
WHAT THEY'VE GONE IN INTO THESE
CRAFT FOR REASON THEY GIVE ME A
BREAK BECAUSE IT'S A LOWER COST
FOR THE CRAFT BREWERIES THE
DESIGN THIS IS SOME SORT OF
WHAT I DON'T KNOW HOW IT THAT
BUT THEY DECIDED ALL THE CRAFT
BREWERS AGREED THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE BEER BOTTLE OF
OREGON RIGHT. WE CAN DUPLICATE
WE CAN COPY IT FOR WHATEVER AND
THEY IN THEIR FIRST YEAR WHEN
THEY START THIS DAY THEY'VE GOT
TO OBTAIN MILLION YOU THINK
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GET OUR
SIX MILLION BY YEAR THREE
OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN LOOK AT
CALIFORNIANS SAY THE SAME
THING. SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
YOUR YOUR CRAFT. YOUR BARS AND
YOUR ESPERANZA HAVE THESE
RECYCLED ARE. REUSABLE BOTTLES
AND THEY HAVE THAT THE
CONTAINERS YOU KNOW THAT THE
CASE AND THEY SIMPLY PUT THE
BOTTLES BACK IN. THIS PROGRAM
THIS PRIVATE INDUSTRY. OBESE RC
TAKES THEM BACK WASHES
SOMETHING GIVE SOME BACK TO.
GET SOME BACK TO THE FOLKS ITS
WILDLY SUCCESSFUL THEY THE-
WINE INDUSTRY HAS COME TO THEM
VOLUNTARILY BECAUSE ORGANS GOT
YOU KNOW IT'S- THERE. THEY'RE
ALL CALLS LIKE NEW HAMPSHIRE
IT'S BUT STATE RUN YOU GOTTA GO
TO STATE. CUT PLACE THAT A WAR
TO DO IT SO THEY'RE NOT PART OF
THEIR THEIR PROGRAM THEY'VE
COME TO THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE
LOOKING AT HALF BOTTLES YOU
KNOW THE HAVE BALLS WITH
THEY'RE GOING TO DESIGN THEIR
WHOLE THING SAID THAT- SO
PEOPLE DRINK LAST. DRINK
RESPONSIBLY SO IT'S GONNA BE A
HALF BOTTLE THAT THEY WANT TO
HAVE PUT INTO THIS PROGRAM TO
HAVE IT GO WIN SO THERE AGAIN
CLOSING THAT LOOP. AND THE
CARBON BENEFIT. IS A FRACTION
AS IT SAYS RIGHT THERE OF THE
EVEN OF THE RECYCLE GLASS IT'S
ONE OF THOSE THINGS AS WE IT'S
ALL HANDS ON DECK AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CAN MATCH OR AGAIN.
ON BREWERIES OF MICRO BREWERIES
AND WINERIES AND THIS
REASONABLE HERE FROM SOME OF
THE- CONCERNED PEOPLE OF THIS
BILL THAT THEY YOU KNOW THEY
THAT SAID. THAT WE GOT A MARKET
HERE NEXT SLIDE. SO WHERE ARE
YOU WHAT'S HAPPENING RE. REFER
BALLS THIS IS A CUTTING EDGE IN
OREGON AND WILL BE CUTING EDGE
IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT DOING
ANY REFILL POLLS ONCE UPON A
TIME. WE REFILL OUR BY. NOW WE
TW ZERO. WE DO WE DO ZERO SO
LATIN AMERICA THE CANADIANS
EUROPE THIS IS THIS IS ONE OF
THE THINGS WERE AS WE AGAIN
IT'S NOT THE WHOLE ANSWER THE
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT IT'S ANOTHER
ANSWER TO SAY. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE OUT SOME OF THESE SOME OF
THESE BEVERAGES AND REUSE THEM
I MEAN I'M OLD ENOUGH. TO
REMEMBER THAT YOU KNOW WHEN I.
WHEN I HAD ANY MONEY I BOUGHT A
PEPSI I WOULD BREAK THAT BOTTLE
GOT CLEANED AND THEY GOT RE.
USE THAT'S GONE. FOR SOME
REASON SAID AND THIS IS THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNE LEAST. SAYING
REFILL IT AND PEOPLE FEEL GOOD
ABOUT IT. AND THEY DRINK THE
BEER. NEXT LIFE. THAT'S IT
THAT'S IT SO. MISTER CHAIR
DEPENDING ON HOW YOU WANT TO IF
YOU WANT HAVE QUESTIONS ON THIS
I'M PREPARED TO. PRESENT MY
OPENING STATEMENT ON THE BILL.
IS IT NO THAT WAS JUST. THERE
WAS A TEASER. ON OPENING
STATEMENT ON BILL I HAVE A
COUPLE OF WITNESSES THAT ARE
HERE- OKAY ONCE YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED OKAY. SO
I SHOULD. OKAY MOVE OVER. SOME
MEMBERS AND- MISTER CHAIR LET
ME BE PERFECTLY CLEAR FROM THE
OUTSET. OUR OUR CHAIR OF
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY HAS WON
THE MOST IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL BILLS- OF THIS
SESSION SB FIFTY FOUR AND I'M
PROUD TO BE A CO. AUTHOR OF
THAT AND HOPEFULLY SB FIFTY
FOUR GIVES CALIFORNIA A MANDATE
TO MOVE OUR FAILED BOTTLE BILL
PROGRAM INTO AN E. P. R.
PROGRAM LED BY STUART
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL RUN BY
BUSINESSES HOWEVER IS. SB FIFTY
FOUR CONTINUES DISCUSSIONS AND
NEGOTIATIONS IN THE CAPABLE
HANDS OF OUR OF OUR CHAIR I
BRING FORWARD THREE SEVENTY TWO
AS- A BACKSTOP. I'M SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO IS A COMPREHENSIVE
BOTTLE REFORM BILL DOESN'T DEAL
WITH SINGLE USE PLASTIC IT
DOESN'T DEAL WITH THAT SYSTEM
FOLLOW REFORM BILL AND WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS AND TALKED
ABOUT THIS AND TALKED ABOUT.
FIXES CALIFORNIA'S ANTIQUATED
BEVERAGE CONTAINER REDEMPTION
RECYCLING PROGRAM. THE BILL IS
THE SAME AS AS BE ONE SIXTY
EIGHT WHICH THIS COMMITTEE.
REVIEWED AND VOTED ON IN A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND ONE THAT I
AND A CONCEPT THAT I'M
COMMITTED TO WORK ON AS IS
NECESSARY AS WE GO THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY. SB THREE SEVEN TWO
IT'S BASED ON THE INPUT FROM
GOVERNOR BROWN'S STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS DURING HIS FINAL TERM.
ALSO THIS COMMITTEE'S OVERSIGHT
HEARING AT TWENTY SEVENTEEN AS
WELL AS THE LA. RIVER IS IN A
KELP RECYCLING WHITE PAPER IN
CAMINO. CONSUMER WATCHDOGS
TRASH IN THE KNOW ME AS REPORT
ON THE ROOF REFORM OF A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE THE TIME IS
NOW ON THE CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RE PROGRAM WHICH IS
ARE AVAILABLE FOR ANYBODY
WHO'D- LIKE THEM. IT'S MINE
QUITE A BIT ON THE ORGANS
GRAHAM THAT'S WHY WE THOUGHT WE
WOULD GIVE YOU A SCAR ON THE-
CAN PROGRAM I'M IN. THOSE
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS AND THE
ADMINISTRATORS PROGRAM ARE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THAT PEOPLE WOULD HAVE. ON IT
ONCE TIME TO THE TO BE CLEAR
THIS IS HOW ORGANS DOESN'T
IMPLEMENT RIGHT COULD BE. UNDER
YOUR BILL THERE'S FLEXIBILITY-
YEAH THE WHATEVER THE
COOPERATIVE THIS DECIDES WE ARE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM FROM-
ORGAN AND THINGS THAT ARE
WORKING AT THINGS THAT ARE NOT
WORKING BUT- BUT WE WILL TURN
IT OVER TO- THE- BACK. CELL
OKAY BEVERAGE. CONTAINER
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION. YOU
KNOW ONCE UPON A TIME THE
BOTTLE BILL IN CALIFORNIA WAS
THAT THE TALK OF THE TOWNIT
WAS A NATIONAL LEADER IN
RECYCLING WE POST THE- POST
ABOUT IT IT WAS SUCCESSFUL IN
PREVENTING BILLIONS OF BOTTLES
AND CANS. FROM BECOMING WINNER
AND GOING INTO OUR LANDFILL AND
BETTER YET MANY THOSE BILLIONS.
OF BOTTLES HAVE BEEN RECYCLED
SOME SAVING ENERGY AS WE START
SAVING WATER SAVING RESOURCES
RESOURCES HOWEVER THIRTY YEARS
LATER. AND OVER SEVENTY FIVE
BILLS THERE BEEN SEVENTY FIVE
BILLS ARE AS I LIKE TO SAY
SEVENTY FIVE. AND THE STRUCTURE
NO LONGER REFLECTS THE NEEDS
AND NO LONGER AFFECTS THE
CAPABILITIES IT NO LONGER
REFLECTS THE TECHNOLOGIES
AVAILABLE TO MAXIMIZE THE
VALUES. OF THE VALUABLE
RESOURCES WHAT CUTTING BACK
WICKS NOW THE PREVIOUS PUSH.
FOR MAJOR REFORM LAID OUT THREE
PRINCIPLES FIRST TO IMPROVE
IMPROVING RECYCLING AND
REMANUFACTURING SECOND SHARING
THE RESPONSIBILITIES LET ME
UNDER SCORE THAT SHARING THE
RESPONSIBILITIES BETWEEN
CONSUMERS MANUFACTURERS
DISTRIBUTORS RECYCLABLES
CURBSIDE FOLKS WASTE HAULERS
MUNICIPALITIES AND ALL OF US.
IN THREE ENHANCING ADAPTABILITY
AND SUSTAINABILITY SO LET'S
BREAK THOSE DOWN FOR IMPROVING
RECYCLING AND THEN
REMANUFACTURING MY BUILT
RESTRUCTURES PAYMENTS AND
PROCEDURES FOR RECYCLING TO
ALLOW MORE STABILITY. AND TO
ALLOW MORE FLEXIBILITY. I THEN
THE CURRENT SYSTEM THERE BEEN
ALSO STE EXPAND THE PROGRAM FOR
ONE NINE THE DISTILLED SPIRITS
AND THEY ARE INCLUDED. WITH
THOSE BEVERAGES HERE IN SB
THREE SEVEN TWO BY INCLUDING
WINE AND SPIRITS DISTILLED
SPIRITS WE INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF BOTTLES IN THIS PROGRAM BY
NINE HUNDRED BILLION OR NINE
HUNDRED MILLION OR BILLION
BOTTLES. PER YEAR PER YEAR.
SECOND PRINCIPLE SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY MY BILL REQUIRES
CAL RECYCLE TO DEVELOP MINIMUM
CONTENT REQUIREMENTS FOR
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THIS BILL
CLOSES THE LOOP RECYCLING AND
ENSURES A MARKET FOR RECYCLABLE
MATERIALS. REPEAT STOP. INTO
THE FUTURE. THE THIRD PRINCIPLE
ENHANCING ADAPTABILITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY SB. PROVIDES
THAT PAYMENTS DO NOT NEED TO
RELY ON THE FLUCTUATING PRICE
OF SCRAP METAL THAT'S ONE
REASONS WHY THESE CONVENIENCE
CENTERS THAT WERE WORRIED ABOUT
WEEK WITH THAT AS A LIMóN GOES
DOWN OR IS THE PRICE OF OIL
GOES DOWN THERE THE VIRGIN OIL
COMES IN WE'RE NOT DOING THAT
YOU GET YOU PAY A DIME YOU GET
A DIME. DONE AND THEM THE
DISTRIBUTORS IN THE MANUFACTURE
TAKE CARE AND IF THE
ORGANIZATION CHOOSES TO PLAY A
FAT TO PROCESSORS AND RECYCLE.
THE BILL ALLOWS WHAT'S THE BILL.
SEVEN TWO. THE CREATE YOUR
BREEDER I'M SUCH A PROGRAM ONE
IT INVOLVES ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS IT EXPANDS THE
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE WINE AND
DISTILLED SPIRITS AND THIS IS
THE ONE FOR ART LIMITED
GOVERNMENT FOLKS IT LIMITS CAL
RECYCLES ROLE BUT NOT ITS
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE THINGS RECYCLE BUT
THEIR HANDS HANDS OFF IT
PROVIDES AN INTERIM REPRIEVE
FOR THE AND UNSERVED
CONVENIENCE ON BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE AND
THAT'S SORT OF WHERE THE ACTION
IS FAN BUT LEGISLATION AND
FINALLY IT REQUIRES CAL RECYCLE
TO STATE MINIMUM CONTENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR BOTTLES.
SIMPLY PUT I CAN'T EMPHASIZE
THIS ENOUGH MEMBERS. EVERYONE
IS IN THERE ARE NO MORE CARVE
OUTS WE'RE DONE WITH THE CAR
BALLOTS THAT'S BEEN THE LEGACY
OF THIS BOTTLE BILL FOR THE
LAST THIRTY. FOR YEARS SEVEN
THIRTY THIRTY PLUS YEARS THIRTY
PLUS YEARS IN THE STAKEHOLDERS
PLAY ON THE SAME PLAYING FIELD
AND THE STATE DOES NOT DOES
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO DO THE
STATE SETS THE GOAL IT OVERSEAS
TO PROGRAM AND WE'RE NOT RUN
IN. THE PROGRAM. NOW THE
STAKEHOLDERS KNOW THEIR
INDUSTRY BASS THEY CAN JOIN THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER-
STEWARDSHIP. ORGANIZATION OR
BACK SO THEY CAN WORK IT OUT
THEY CAN NEGOTIATED THEY CAN
COME UP WITH THE AGREEMENT OF
WHAT THE PLAN IS GOING TO BE
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE US. IT'S
SB THREE SEVEN TWO IS A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO A
COMPLEX PROBLEM. NOW WITH ME
TODAY. OH MY GOD. ON THE
GOVERNOR OR HE IS MY NEPHEW FOR
GOD'S SAKE OKAY IS THIS WITH ME
TODAY IS SARAH EDWARDS WITH
WHO'S FROM NOMA AND I PUT UP
THE REPORT THAT THEY HAVE THE
KNOW ME I CAN ONLY A IS THE
GREEK GODDESS OF GOOD
GOVERNMENT WHAT A GREAT NAME.
AS WELL AS AS CHUCK RECALL FROM
TARA SO WITH YOUR INDULGENCE I
WOULD LIKE MY FIRST WITNESS
BEGAN. THANK YOU EIGHT. AM IS
WHEN I'M SURPRISED WITH SOME
YOU KNOW IDEA EVERY SETTING SO
TING WHERE WE THE WORLD'S
LEADER THIS CONSOLE TO.
ADVISEMENT TO CONSULTANCY IN
DEPOSIT SYSTEM SIDE WE HAVE
LET'S REVIEWS. THE FIFTY
SYSTEMS- OPERATING ACROSS
ALLOWED FROM THOSE ACROSS
EUROPE TO THOSE IN AUSTRALIA-
AND A CAR IN THE PRICES OF
DESIGNING SYSTEMS IN THE U. K.
INDONESIA. HONG KONG SO WE SIT.
AND THAT SHOULD. JUST LET US BY
THE TERMS OF THE TYPE. I'M I WE
ARE IN SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
PRIVATE PRIMARILY BECAUSE IT
MAYES TO THAT SHED
RESPONSIBILITY MODEL THAT WE
SEE THAT SUCCESSFUL IN OTHER
OTHER COUNTRIES- IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE DID A FULL
REVIEW OF THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
THE CALIFORNIA CALLING
LEGISLATION IS THE LARGEST
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WE'VE SEEN
IT CONTAINED ON CONTENDED
DEPOSITS IN THE WILD- IT THIS
THE PRESCRIPTIVE NATURE THE
BILL MIGHT BE ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE MET NEED A NEEDED THANK
THE SYSTEM SUSTAINABLE TO TAKE
PLACE. AND I THINK THAT OF LIKE
HOUSEKEEPER POINTED OUT SOME
VERY IMPORTANT POINTS IN TIMES
OF HOW WELL OF MONEY- AND THE
REST ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
AND ALL CLEA AFFECTS BUT TO
THIS. SUCCESS WHEN THE FUTURE.
OF. AB I OUR REVIEW OF THE
SYSTEM NINETY THOUSAND ECON
LEGISLATION. ACTIVE AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT FOUND THAT YOU KNOW
IT FILE TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE OVER
THE NEXT LEVEL OF CONVENIENCE
THAT CONSUMERS NEED TO BE OUT
TO HIM AND THE TEAM THAT
DEPOSIT AND COLLECT THAT SEE
AVE AB UNDRESS SYSTEM THAT WE
WOULD PROPOSE AND WE LIKE TO
SEE THAT THIS IS A THE
LEGISLATION EFFECTIVELY SETS A
LEVEL OF REDEMPTION THAT THE
SCHEME TO ACHIEVE. THE LEVEL OF
RECYCLING I'M I'M REDEMPTION
RIGHT AND ALLOWS THE PRODUCES
AND THE STEWARDS TO AFFECT WE
PUT IN PLACE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
NETWORK OF REDEMPTION. AND
POINTS TO ALLOW THAT I'M SYSTEM
TO. HE PUT IN PLACE AND THAT
LEVEL OF CONVENIENCE AND PLACES
AB OWNERSHIP ON THE PRODUCES
TONIGHT SO THAT THE NUMBER OF
REDEMPTION POINTS AND PROVIDES
A LEVEL OF CONVENIENCE- WITH OF
THE CITY CODE WHAT HOUSE THE
BILL ALSO ALLOWS FULL. I'M AN
AMENDMENT IN THE DEPOSIT LEVEL
THAT WILL ALLOW AND THAT TO BE
TO BE AMENDED IF FOR- FOR
INSTANCE THE ABDUCTION RIGHT
FOR THIS I'LL ADMIT NECESSARY
STRATEGY- REQUIREMENT. SO IN IN
ESSENCE WE SUPPORT THE BILL
IT'S NICE TO MOVE THAT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY MODEL I'M AND
I'M BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
SOME. AMENDMENTS THE NEEDING TO
THE CURRENT DRAFTING TO MAKE IT
A SEAT WILL BILL FIVE EXIST BY
THAT IN CALIFORNIA. I'M SORRY
MISTER CHAIR I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
THIS IS JAMIE QUIRK. FROM
CONSUMER WATCH I DIDN'T LOOK
OVER I WAS SO GALVANIZED ON MY
SLIDES. MY NEXT WITNESS. HI
JAMIE COURT PRESIDENT CONSUMER
WATCHDOG I'LL KEEP IT REAL
SIMPLE YOU KNOW CALIFORNIANS
PAY ABOUT A BILLION AND A HALF
DOLLARS IN NICKELS AND DIMES
AND WE'RE GETTING A LITTLE LESS
THAN HALF BACK THE OFFICIAL
REDEMPTION STATE THE NUMBER
FROM CAL RECYCLE NOW IS SIXTY
EIGHT PERCENT. WE BELIEVE IT'S
ACTUALLY LOWER. IN OREGON IT'S
THE 1% IN MICHIGAN IT'S 89% IN
GERMANY IT'S 98% AND THE REASON
IS BECAUSE THEY ALL DO ONE
THING THAT WE DON'T DO AND IT'S
WE TELL THE BEVERAGE COMPANIES
THAT ARE PROFITING FROM THE
RAPPERS FROM THE CANS BOTTLES
THAT THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
RECYCLING THAT IS THE CONCEPT
BEHIND THE BILL THAT WE
SUPPORT. AND WE THINK SHOULD
MOVE FORWARD AND BECOME LAW AND
I THINK EVEN THE PEOPLE WHO
OPPOSE THIS BILL SUPPORT THAT
CONCEPT SO I REALLY THINK AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THAT'S THE CONCEPT
TO KEEP IN MIND THERE ARE
THINGS WE WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE
ABOUT THIS BILL AND WE HOPE DO.
LIKE ALL RETAILERS HAVE TO
ACCEPT. I WAS ON CAMPUS. AS WE
BUY BOTTLES AND CANS IN RETURN
IN THE SAME PLACE THAT WORKS.
IT'S SIMPLE IT'S CONVENIENCE
WOULD LIKE THAT TO BE IN THIS
BILL. WE'D LIKE TO SEE-
CURBSIDE HOLLERS WERE GETTING
PAID NOW FOR TWELVE PERCENT. OF
OUR NICKELS AND DIMES NOT GET
THAT PAYMENT. BECAUSE THEY
DON'T GET IN ANYWHERE ELSE AND
THEY'RE NOT AUDITED I GOT TO
TALK TO COVER CYCLE ABOUT IT.
BUT THE CONCEPT OF THIS BILL IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT AND IF
WE CAN ALL KEEP THAT IN MIND
EVEN AS YOU'RE HEARING THE
OPPOSITION. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE LAST THING
I'LL SAY THAT I HOPE HAPPENS
WITH THIS BILL HOPE HAPPENS
THIS YEAR IS THERE ARE
RECYCLERS WE HAVE HALF THE
RECYCLING CENTERS WE DID. YOU
KNOW A DECADE AGO- AND- THEY'VE
CLOSED BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT AN
ADEQUATE PAYMENTS ARE HIGHER
RENT THEIR SARS MEN WHICH BUT
THE ONES THAT HAVE. HIGH
QUALITY HIGH VOLUME THESE ARE
CENTERS THAT ARE PRODUCING. AND
THEY EXIST IN THE SYSTEM THEY
SHOULD BE REWARDED. AND UNTIL
WE TRANSITION TO THE SYSTEM WE
NEED TO PAY THEM. WE GOT THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN THE
BANK FROM HUNDRED TEAM DEPOSIT.
LET'S PAY THEM TO KEEP DOING
THIS JOB AND WE'LL- DO THIS NEW
SYSTEM. LET'S MAKE SURE. THAT
THEY HAVE FIRST DIBS. WITH
THEM. AND I THINK IF WE- WERE
GONNA REDUCE A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL. AND
WE'RE GONNA CHANGE ASSISTANCE
TO PEOPLE OR IN A 90% RETENTION
RATE WE'RE SAVING THE
ENVIRONMENT PROTECTING THE
CONSUMERS. THERE ARE THAT MANY
WHEN WHEN'S IN THIS BUILDING
THIS BILL. BE THAT AND I THINK-
IF ONE UNDERSTAND THE GOVERNOR
WANTS THAT AS WELL. SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR INDULGING IN
THIS IT'S REALLY REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT. TO CONSUMERS I JUST
INVITE. I DON'T. KNOW WHAT THE.
AS OF A QUORUM LET'S LET'S CALL
A CALL QUORUM. SENATOR ALLEN.
PRESENT SENATOR BATES. SENATOR
DOLLY SENATOR HEALTH CENTER
SKINNER SENATOR STERN. CENTER
BY CASKEY HERE. I MEAN OKAY BUT
WORK OKAY WELL VERY BRIEFLY
PLEASE YEAH OKAY THAT'S FINE
YEAH- JUST THAT MORNING-
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHUCK
REGAL I AM A SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE TIMER SYSTEMS
IN THE AMERICAS- OUR COMPANIES
A LEADER PROVIDER OF TECHNOLOGY
AND SERVICES IN THE SIXTY PLUS
DEPOSITS. OF AN EYE WORK ON ON
THIS POLICY IN THE US AND
CANADA- WE DID OPERATE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA UNTIL WE SOLD FOR
ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS UNTIL WE
SOLD OUR BUSINESS IN TWENTY
TEN. OF MUCH BECAUSE OF THE
SAME ISSUES THAT THAT THE
MARKET'S GOING THROUGH BANK.
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT IT I GUESS
WITH SOBRE WITH EXPECTATION
THAT IF THE- IF THERE IS A REAL
CONSIDERATION FOR REAL REFORM
RATHER THAN FIXES- THAT WE
WOULD CONSIDER REINVESTING IN
THIS MARKET. THE CHALLENGES
THAT ARE BEING DISCUSSED. ARE
EVER GONNA BE DISCUSSED ARE ARE
ON ON BOTH SIDES ARE ARE NOT
FOUND IN HIGH PERFORMING-
PROGRAMS PER PROGRAMS AND I'VE
GOT ORGAN WE TALK ABOUT- WE'VE
GOT MICHIGAN GERMANY NORWAY. OF
CONSUMERS HAVE ACCESS TO
THOUSANDS OF POINTS OF
RETURNED- AND- IN ITS MADE EASY
FOR THEM. AND BECAUSE THE- THE
ELEMENTS OF THE CHRIS
RESPONSIBILITY ELEMENTS THE-
BEVERAGE PRODUCERS THE
RETAILERS. ARE ABLE DESIGN ABLE
TO DESIGN A SYSTEM SOME SORT OF
ON THEIR OWN TERMS FOR AND ARE
ABLE SEAT COST EFFICIENCY.
FRAUD PROTECTION. BEFORE ME
REDEMPTION THE FOR THE CONSUMER
AND THE PRETTY TENSE AND IT
ALSO ALLOWS FOR INNOVATION- AND
THAT'S THE AND IT'S AT EIGHT PM
THE ABILITY TO HAVE INNOVATION
OF FLEXIBILITY. THANK YOU JUST
CUT COMPANIES LIKE OURS. OF
THESE MARKETS HAVE CREATED
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES AND WE-
LIKE I SAID BEFORE WOULD LIKE
TO INVEST AGAIN- LIKE WE DID
BACK IN THE NINETIES WHEN WE
TRY TO BRING SOME SOME
INNOVATION TO THIS PROGRAM. OF
WE EXPECT THE BILL WILL BE
FURTHER IMPROVED. AND I REQUEST
THE COMMITTEE APPROVE SB SEVEN
THREE SEVENTY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU THESE ARE MUCH OKAY. ARE
FOLKS WHO WANT TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL I'M JUST.
THIS TO CHEN MEMBERS JUST MILAN
FOR THE STORY OF STUFF A STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT NEEDS
AN OVERHAUL AND IT SHOULD BE
COMPLEMENTARY WITH SB FIFTY
FOUR. ONCE YOU WORK THROUGH THE
PROCESS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE SHERIN MARK MURRAY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE- THERE ARE THREE.
CONCEPTS IN THIS BILL THAT I'M
SUPPORTING- I'M SUPPORTING THIS
CONCEPT OF GREATER PRODUCE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE COST
RECYCLING- I'M SUPPORTING
CONCEPT OF. NEW AUTHORITY TO
CAL RECYCLE FOR MINIMUM
RECYCLED CONTENT. AND THE
PROPOSED EXPANSION OF THE LAW-
TO INCLUDE ONE STILL SPIRITS
ALL THOSE ARE GOOD FEATURES OF
THIS. I JUST HAVE TO CLARIFY
TWO POINTS THAT WERE MADE IN
THE PRESENTATION NUMBER ONE. NO
TAX DOLLARS ARE USED IN THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM TO FUND THE
RECYCLING PROGRAM. IS ENTIRELY
PAID FOR BY SEPARATE THE
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY AND BEVERAGE
CANS. SECONDLY I LIKE THE FACT
THAT OUR OUR PROGRAM ALLOWS ME
TO PUT BEVERAGE CONTAINERS IN
MY CURBSIDE RECYCLING PROGRAM
AND THAT I'VE PAID THE REFUND
VALUE ON. AND THE VALUE OF THAT
REFUND VALUE OF CREWS TO HELP
OFFSET THE RATE TO THE CURBSIDE
RECYCLING THAT'S A GOOD FEATURE
OF OUR PROGRAM AND I HOPE THAT
THIS POLICY IF THERE IS A PLAN
AND IF IT MOVES FORWARD. THAT
WE WOULDN'T GET RID OF THAT
FEATURE BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
FAIR CONSUMER. THAT WANT TO
USE. A RECYCLING PROGRAM.
THANKS. BUT WHEN YOU'RE YOU ARE
ON WE HAVE YOU ON AS IN SUPPORT
THE OKAY I JUST SAID HERE THE
THREE THINGS ABOUT BUILDING I'M
SUPPORTING. RIGHT THANK YOU OR
SO KILLS HERE ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL WORST PART OF THE
INTENT OF THE BILL WE- WE
APOLOGIZE FOR A LETTER ON TO
LAND A LETTER BUT WE SUPPORT
THE INTENT TO COMPREHENSIVELY
CLEAN UP THE STATUE AND
PROBABLY FIX THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I CAN YOU
ALONG WITH MEANS RECYCLING HOW
WE OPERATE RECYCLING CENTER-
LOCALLY HERE IN SACRAMENTO- FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS- AND ALSO-
THREE PROCESSING FACILITIES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONCEPT WITH
THIS BILL- BUT THERE'S A
THERE'S A LOT THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE- INPUT I THINK FROM THE
STAKEHOLDER OFTEN PEOPLE LIKE
US. I TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A SEAT ON THE
TABLE- YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF CONCERN RIGHT NOW. I WITH A
LOT OF CUSTOMERS THAT WE DEAL
WITH YOU KNOW HIS PROGRAM. THIS
IS ALL PM AND THE BACKDROP.
PLACE ALL EXIST RECYCLING
CENTER NOT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
HAVING THESE. IT IS HELLO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE HOW THAT'S
GONNA YOU KNOW. HOW THAT'S
GONNA WORK- IS IT GONNA YOU
KNOW IT'S REALLY GONNA
CONCERNED A LIVELIHOOD OF ART
YOU KNOW I BUSINESSES RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU. IS RESOURCES HAYWARD
AND WITH PROTECT CRV AND AGAIN
WE DO SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF
THREE SEVENTY TWO BOB WHEN WE
HAD PROBLEMS WITH ALL THE
RECYCLING CENTERS CLOSE SEEN IN
THE SUMMER WE HAD ONE SENATOR
COME TO OUR FACILITY ND I WAS
CENTER WHITE HOUSE SKI- SHE WAS
THE ONLY ONE THAT RESPONDED TO
THE NEEDS OF RECYCLING CENTERS
SO- TAKING A STEP FORWARD AND
SERVER FROM WE DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THAT. THINGS WERE
PERSON IN THE PROCESS OF.
APPLYING FOR ONE. MS PRODUCED
BACKDROP PROGRAM. WITH A
PATENTED PROCESS TO THE CITY OF
WHOLESOME AND- TO THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AREAS OF
ARDEN ARCADE CARMICHAEL SO
REDUCE TO SUPPORT IT. ANY JUST
MENTION BEFORE WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT- THERE'S A GOOD
TRANSITION FOR THE EXISTING
RECYCLING CENTERS THANK YOU
YEP. YEP OKAY. I LET'S HEAR
FROM FOLKS WHO WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. IF I MAY
I MEN WHAT WHAT WAS SO WHERE
THE LEAD TO DO YOU GUYS HAVE
SOME LEAD. THE TV ORGANIZED
OKAY WHAT THE TWO OF YOU COME
UP THEN AND YOU CAN JOINED
DEREK AND I AM NEITHER AND
SUPPORT NOR OPPOSITION OKAY.
YOU ARE MOST AMERICANS. YEAH
YEAH IS IT ALRIGHT SELLING-
SURE SURE IT WAS HERE WHAT'S
YOUR TENS UNIT YOU CAN COME UP
AND HAVE SIX I'M SUSAN COLLINS
FROM THE CONTAINER RECYCLING
INSTITUTE- AND WE APPLIED- THE
VISION OF THIS BILL AND MANY
DETAILED PROVISIONS OF THE
PROPOSED NEW PROGRAM ARE VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND TRULY WORLD
CLASS AND THERE ARE NOW MORE
THAN SIXTY CONTAINER DEPOSIT
LAWS WORLDWIDE BECAUSE AT
BELARUS WAS SENT OUT YESTERDAY
THEY BECAME NUMBER SIXTY ONE.
AND THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS. BEVERAGE CAN DEPOSIT
BOSS HAS. THREE HUNDRED MILLION
PEOPLE THE YEAR TO SIX HUNDRED
MILLION ONCE THESE NEW PROGRAMS
ARE ALL IMPLEMENTED. AND HIS
UNIQUE NO OTHER CONTAINER
DEPOSIT PROGRAM IN THE WORLD
HAS LOST HALF ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE THE PROBLEMS
THAT PLAGUE THE CURRENT PROGRAM
OUR UNIQUE TO THE STRUCTURE AND
INFLEXIBILITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
LAW. SO AGAIN WHILE WE APPLAUD
THE VISION FOR THE NEW PROGRAM
THAT WOULD GO INTO PLACE IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WERE ALSO
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO PEOPLE AND- REFUNDS
IN THE INTERVENING FOR YEARS.
I'M WE'VE GOT THESE RECYCLING
DESERT IN THE STATE. HELP IS
NEEDED WE'VE LOST HALF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE WE LOST THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SITES LAST YEAR
WE LOST IN ELEVEN SITES JUST IN
THE LAST MONTH. THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER REDEMPTION CENTERS.
UNDERPAID SIXTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE
HAVE A CRAZY PAYMENT FORMULA
WHERE THE PAYMENTS ARE DOWN 20%
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS. BUT
THEIR COSTS ARE UP 20% OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS OF COURSE THAT
TEN WORKABLE. AND AS A RESULT
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE
COLLECTING IS A HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE MILLION MORE IN DEPOSIT
REFUNDS NOW THAN THEY ARE BUT
THEY CAN'T BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE WORD ANYWHERE TO GO. WE
NEED PAYMENTS HAWAII HAS MADE
TO CHANGE AND THEY'RE SHORING.
STRUCTURE SO IF THEY CAN'T DO
IT I THINK WE CAN TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO YOU BUT THOUGHT
THE ORGAN. IF YOU SPEND TIME
LEVEL. GO DUCKS YEAH ALL RIGHT
YES. GOOD MORNING RIGHT SO
TIM'S MOTHER REPRESENTING WINE
INSTITUTE- WE'RE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION- TODAY TO THIS
LEGISLATION UP. I GUESS A ALSO
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS I'D
LIKE TO SAY ABOUT IT- WE ARE IN
AGREEMENT I ACTUALLY THE- THE
GENTLEMAN FROM THE CONSUMER
WATCHDOG I PICKED OUT THE SAID
PRETTY WELL THE OPPOSITE TEN
AGREES WITH THE YOU KNOW REFORM
OF THIS ANTIQUATED PROGRAM IS
LAW. OR DO WE RE WITHOUT. WE
ALSO IN GREECE RE THAT
INDUSTRIES LED. CHEN IS A
BETTER MODEL THAN THAN WHAT WE
SEEN UNDER CAL RECYCLE
UNFORTUNATELY KINDA HARD STOP
THAT'S WHAT WE LIKE- SO FAR OF.
GERMAN ALLEN IS AS YOU'RE AWARE.
OUR OUR INDUSTRY AND OUR
FRIENDS- HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCES TO
WORKING WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK OF
YOUR LEGISLATION- THAT'S BEING
CONSIDERED RIGHT NOW AND WHILE
WE'RE NOT THERE YET. WE THINK
THAT THAT ALLOWS FOR THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WOULD. MANAGE
OUR PRODUCTS- WE STRONGLY
DISAGREE WITH THE NOTION THAT A
DEPOSIT REFUND SYSTEM WORKS FOR
OUR PRODUCTS AND AS- I THINK
YOU NOTED WINE BOTTLES
CURRENTLY AREN'T PART OF THE
OREGON PROGRAM. AND JUST TO
MAKE THAT VERY REAL FOR WHY
THAT PROBABLY IS- IF YOU DID
THIS BAG PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE
WINE BOTTLES ARE VERY HAPPY
SPIRITS BALLS- SAME DEAL- TO
GET A FIVE DOLLAR REFUND
THROUGH THE ORGAN SYSTEM IT
SEEMS THAT WOULD BE LIKE AND
SET THE BOTTLE. AND IT'S LIKE
OVER A FIFTY POUND BAG BUT
YOU'D BE ASKING THE HOLLOW
SOUND. AND WE'RE- TALKING ABOUT
THE INCIDENT ALL OF YOU BE IN
ONE OF ACCESS TO RECYCLING. WE
FEEL THE DIALOGUE NEEDS TO BE
FOCUSED ON TWELVE ACCESS TO
RECYCLING THE CURBSIDE PROGRAM
WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON THAT-
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE.
MOVING BEYOND THE DEPOSIT
REFUND SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOCUSING ON
IMPROVING THE CONVENIENCE TO
CONSUMERS. AND GETTING RID OF
THIS INSTANTLY COMPLEX AND
ANTIQUATED SYSTEM THAT WE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCE WITH THE
EXISTING BOTTLED. SO I CAN SEE
THAT WE FIND IT UNFORTUNATE
THAT THIS BILL WAS INTRODUCED-
PLAN IN THE MANNER ANTI MEAN
AND IS IT AS IT WAS- YOUR YOUR
CHOICE OBVIOUSLY SENATOR. BUT
WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF A MUCH
BROADER DISCUSSED AND- THAT
WERE AT THE TABLE OR RIGHT NOW
AND WE HOPE THAT THIS DOESN'T
DISTRACT FROM THAT
CONVERSATION. SO WITHOUT- I
REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE HOLD
THE BILL RIGHT NOW AND HOW IT.
OKAY I ONE OF HIS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL OUR POSITION.
CAN COME TO MY. YOU CAN SAY TO
MY PHONE ORGAN. SIR CAN. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARK A PRAYER I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES AND
WE- WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION
ON THE MEASURE BUT AS WE'VE
EXPRESSED TO THE AUTHOR WITH
WHOM WE HAVE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP A GREAT DEAL OF
RESPECT WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE MEASURE AND
WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS THOSE. TO
THE COMMITTEE. I THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE IS THAT- I THINK
THAT THE C. R. V. PROGRAM
CERTAINLY HAS ITS PROBLEMS AND
HE THAT IS. WITHOUT THE NILE-
BUT THAT DESPITE THESE PROBLEMS
THE CURRENT CRV PROGRAMMING
CALIFORNIA ACCORDING TO CAL
RECYCLES LATEST FIGURES. IS
SEVENTY FIVE POINT EIGHT
PERCENT. RECYCLING RATE. THAT
IS HIGHER THAN ANY E. P. R.
PROGRAM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND SO WHEN PEOPLE
POINT TO OREGON THE SUCCESS IN
OREGON IN OUR OPINION IS NOT
BECAUSE OF THE ARE IT IS
BECAUSE IT'S AT TEN CENTS. AT
AND THAT THAT TEN CENT
REDEMPTION BY YOU IS WHAT IS
CAUSING THAT SUCCESS TO A IT
THE E. P. R. OP. ART CONCERN
SHOULD BE EXPRESSED THIS WAY
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A FORTY
MILLION OF POPULATION OREGON
HAS FOUR MILLION. AND THOSE
COMPARISONS ARE IMPORTANT NOT
ONLY IN TERMS OF SIZE BUT THE
DIVERSITY OF THE POPULATION AND
THE LARGENESS OF THE GEOGRAPHY
IN CALIFORNIA COMPARED TO
OREGON. AND SO AT THE END WE'D
LIKE TO SAY THAT WE WOULD BE
CONCERNED THAT WE NOT THROW THE
BABY OUT WITH THE BATH WATER-
AND- AS THIS MAY MEASURE MOVES
FORWARD. THAT THERE BE
CONSIDERATION AS TO WHAT'S
REALLY DRIVING THE SUCCESS OF
OTHER PROGRAMS AND THAT WE NOT
JUST SIMPLY WALK AWAY FROM THE
CURRENT PROGRAM THANK YOU. YEAH
MR MEMBERS SAID KEVIN THE QUEUE
UP. THE DISTILLED SPIRITS
COUNCIL WE FULLY ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE WINE
INSTITUTE COMMENTS ON OUR ON
GOING WORK WITH YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. AS WELL AS MISS GETS
ALSO ON THE OTHER SIDE THERE.
YEAH CHAIRED MEMBERS IN THREE
MILLION ON BEHALF OF THE
PLASTIC RECYCLING CORPORATION
OF CALIFORNIA WE DID GET OUR
LETTER IN LATE SO WE APOLOGIZE
WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. I
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE TIM
SCHNAUZER I IN CONCEPT
PHILOSOPHICALLY WE DON'T HAVE
AN ISSUE WITH INDUSTRY LED
DEPOSIT PROGRAM HOWEVER WE DO
BELIEVE- THE CURRENT. PROGRAM
DOES NEED IMMEDIATE
MODIFICATIONS IN THE INTERIM
WHILE WALKING ON THE U.
CONCEPTS THANK YOU. MELISSA
ONE. FAMILY ONE MAKERS OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AS IT IS NOW AND WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF THE WINE INSTITUTE
THANK YOU. FOR WINTER MEMBERS
MICHAEL MILLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WONDER
GROWERS. WE SUCH YOURSELVES IN
THE COMMENTS OF MISTER
SCHMELZER AND RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED ASK ME TO HOLD THE BILL
THANK YOU. DAVID KRIEGER
CALIFORNIA BEER BEVERAGE
DISTRIBUTORS ALSO IN OPPOSITION
FOR MANY REASONS YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD THANK YOU. THESE AS YOU
HAVE THE BEER BEVERAGE AND YOU
GUYS HAVE A DIFFERENT ISSUE IN
TERMS OF THE WEIGHT OF THE
BOTTLES I GUESS COLLECTIVELY.
IT MEANS IS THAT IS THAT IT.
THIS IS THIS IS AN THAT YOUR
FOLKS UP IN OREGON BUT JUST. DO
YOU HAVE COMMENTS ON. THE
EXPERIENCE IN OREGON. FOR YOUR
INDUSTRY- NO NOT AT THE MOMENT
BUT YET WE DO HAVE A LETTER IN
THAT DETAILED SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OVER THAT- BUT I DON'T
THINK THE WAY IS THE- IS THE
HEART OF THAT ISSUE. WHAT SO
WITH OUR THAT FOR YOU. THAT'S
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE THAT ON IT
OKAY OKAY WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AND
FOLLOW UP. SIR OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY I. THINK YOUR BODY ANYONE
ANY OF THIS FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND. SO LET ME START
WITH IS THE QUESTION I GUESS.
YOU KNOW WE'VE ONE OF THE
THINGS WE STRUGGLE WITH THIS
COMMITTEE- WITH WITH EXTENDED
PLEASE RESPONSIBLY PROGRAMS AS
BANDSMEN FORSMAN CHALLENGES.
AND IN OF ONE OF YOUR SUPPORT
WITNESSES WANNA COME UP WE CAN
JUST HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE HERE AT THE AT THE
TABLE. YOU WILL RECEIVE YOUR
YOUR SEATS. CONCERN WITHIN
INDUSTRY HOW DO YOU WHAT WHAT
WHAT IF WE RUN INTO A SIMILAR
ENFORCEMENT ISSUES. WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF. THIS WOULD
BE PASSING A LAW. GIVEN WHAT WE
SEEN WITH CARPETS AND
MATTRESSES AND IN SOME OF THE
OTHER. SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT I'VE BEEN OUT THERE WITH
THE PR SO FAR. WELL I GUESS.
HOW THE CARPET THE PAINT AND
THE MATTRESS. XNA BUT HIS
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE ARE-
PIONEERING EFFORTS TO
CALIFORNIA'S MAKING THE BOTTLE
RECYCLING IS NOT I MEAN WE'RE
WE'RE CUTTING EDGE ON CARPET
AND I ADMIT YOU KNOW YOUR
PARTIES WILL BE BUILDING WILL
BE BUILDING OFF OF WHAT THE
WORLD HAS BEEN DOING IN
RECYCLING BOB. WAS THERE'S I
MEAN HOW MANY TIMES YOU HAVE AN
OLD SHE DON'T KNOW HOW TO OF
PURSES VERSUS A WINE BOTTLE AND
OUT OR A OR A SODA BOTTLE SO
THERE'S A DIFFERENT CONTEXT
THAT WE HAVE A WE HAVE. SUCCESS
OUR NOBLE. MATCH RECYCLING
PROGRAMS IN THE WORLD THAT ARE
SUCCESS THAT WE CAN SAY WE'RE
GONNA BE. OURS TO DO THAT SO IT
IT IT'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
TO YOU SIR DO YOU HAVE YEAH I
MEAN I THINK IT A MODERN SYSTEM
MOVES TO A TECHNOLOGY BASED
SYSTEM. I MEAN YOU SAW SOME OF
THE IN OREGON BUT YOU ALSO SEE
THAT YOU KNOW THAT IN TIMES OF
THIS CENTURY. I'M PRETTY SOLID
STEWARDSHIP SO THEY CAN. WRITE
MEANT THERE IS I'M SO THAT'S
NOT CROSS BORDER FRAUD FOR
INSTANCE THAT IT IN OTHER
ORGANS HAVE INVESTED IN LOOKING
AT LAYS REDEMPTION POINTS AT ON
THE FORD WITH THEM IT STATES
THAT DON'T HAVE A- A DEPOSIT
SYSTEM. AND THERE'S ALSO A
MECHANISM TO ALLOW A TECHNOLOGY
BASED SYSTEMS OF EVERY EVERY
FACTORY EVERY CONTAINER THE
GUYS WHO THIS IS VERIFIED. BY
THE THROUGH AN OFF YET OR SENT
TO. THE. HE TRIED TO
FORTUNATELY. PLAY THE SYSTEM.
SO THAT EFFECTIVELY HELP. AND
RALPH SOFT POLICE EACH OTHER.
IN IN A CONFERENCE ROOM RIGHT
MISTER CHAIR IS THAT YOU KNOW
THIS IS THE FOUNDATION IS THE
FLEXIBILITY AND THE INNOVATION.
AS AS WE'VE- MENTIONED THAT WE
GIVE TO THE COOPERATIVE THEY'RE
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT. ARE
GOING TO DESIGN THIS AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO THEY NEED BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY THEY WILL BE.
RESPONSIBLE AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY WHEN YOU HAVE A AND
A GOVERNMENT AGENCY THAT SO
RESPONSIBILITY UNDER THIS BILL
THERE SO WHAT'S POSSIBILITY
WOULD BE. TO AUDIT. TO VERIFY
TO COME TO SHOW THIS
COMPLIANCE. IT MAKES ME IT
MEANS THAT YOU HAVE A MORE
DEDICATED AGENCY THAT'S LOOKING
AT ONE THING. SHOW THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO THEM TO SHOW THE
PUSH. REGISTERING CORRECTLY TO
ENSURE THAT THE- RECYCLING
RIGHTS BEING AT SO THAT I CAN
THEN AND- IT IS NOT BEING. MET.
EIGHT EIGHT INFO BECAUSE THANKS
IS THE TENSION OF THE AGENCY.
THE TO DO. WHAT'S YOUR I WHAT
THIS DOES THE EXISTING
RECYCLING CENTER INFRASTRUCTURE
WELL THAT TO THE COOPERATIVE I
MEAN IF THEIR THIRST TO TH THIS
IS A LONG TERM FIX OKAY THIS IS
THE BIG FIX IN THE INTERIM WE
HAVE ALL THESEWE HAVE CAL
RECYCLE SITTING ON THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THEY'VE COLLECTED
BECAUSE BECAUSE MY INFORMATION
SAYS THAT CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW
WE'RE RECYCLING 66% OF OUR
PRODUCT COMES IN THE THAT
ALUMINUM OFF THE CHARTS BECAUSE
AT THAT SAID BUT THE BOTTLES
AND CANS PEOPLE ARE SIMPLY NOT
DOING IT THAT'S THAT'S GONNA
BE. FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WEEKEND AND WE'RE GONNA BE
LESS THAN A TWO THIRDS OF RISK
LABOR OUR GOAL IS 80% IT'S A
FAILURE SO WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN THIS THIS THIS WHATEVER
IS GOOD FIGURE IS GOOD IF
YOU'RE NOT IF IT'S IF IT'S
WORKING I JUST OFFERED THE
OREGON MODEL THE BOTTLE DROP
OFF AS IT IDEA IT CAN BE
THEY'RE GOING TO IT'S PRIVATE
INDUSTRY THEY'RE GOING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WORKS BEST IN
THESE DIFFERENT AREAS THEY MAY
GO WITH THAT A DIFFERENT MODEL
FOR PEOPLE TO. DROP OFF. WAR IS.
SOPHISTICATED NO I THINK THAT
RESPECT TEAM IT ANSWER THE
TECHNOLOGY BUT BUT. I'M JUST
YEAH I JUST GOT THE LEGISLATION
THEY'RE GOING TO RUN IT CAN I
JUST MAKE A POINT THAT
ULTIMATELY- DISTRICT PEOPLE
WITH IDEATION IS GONNA HAVE TO
HAVE AS MANY REDEMPTION POINTS-
AS NECESSARY TO BE THE TARGET
SO THEY ARE GOING TO BE
ENCOURAGING THE EXISTING
REDEMPTION NETWORK TO STAY IN
PLACE BECAUSE THAT'S WELL
KNOWN. THE GOING TO BE REQUIRED
TO PAY THE EXISTING AND
REDEMPTION BUT THE NECESSARY
COST TO KEEP THEM IN OPERATION.
THEY ARE GOING TO COVER THAT
COST SO EFFECTIVELY THEY
THEY'LL DOES NOT WAY BILL ONE
IN INFO JUST CLOSED OUT WITH
THE HAVE A TARGET TO ME. TO
MEET AND THEY HAVE TO BRING ALL
THE REDEMPTION RENTAL. THIS
FEATURE SO WE UNDERSTAND. ORGAN
HAS TEN TIMES THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND TODAY THEY HAVE
TWENTY. TWICE AS MANY
REDEMPTION CENTERS. IN A WE
HAVE ONE CHANCE I MEAN.
CALIFORNIA HAS TEN TIMES
POPULATION. THEY HAVE TWICE AS
MANY REDEMPTION CENTERS SO-
THIS CONCERN IT'S A GOOD. YOU
KNOW AGAIN WE HAVE. YOU KNOW
THE CURRENT SYSTEM MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
IT'S GOT WILLIAM CARP. YEAH IF
THE CURBSIDE RECYCLING PROGRAM
IS SO GREAT. THEN COOPERATIVE
WILL SAY WELL WHAT ARE. WE CAN.
TO THE TUNE OF ABOUT FIFTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS MISTER
COURTS- REPORT AND IN THE MIA
EVERY PORT ON THAT WE'RE
SPENDING THAT MONEY AND WE'RE
ALSO FOR CAL RECYCLE JST SEE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE PICKING
THOSE PENSIONS AND THOSE
BENEFITS SO THAT'S GOING TO BE
THAT'S COULD BE PROP INDUSTRIES
THIS IS SO HOW HOW CLOSE IS THE
THIS MORE OF WHAT THE NUMBERS
COLOMBIA'S. PRETTY FAR. IN
DISTRICT. EIGHT SCOTT BEYOND IT
WORKS ALONGSIDE THE EPL
APPROACH. OF THE PACKAGING
MATERIALS I MEAN I EXPERIENCE
IS THAT TO GET THE MAXIMUM
LEVEL OF RISK LIKE WE GET TO
REACH THE HIGHEST LEVEL
RECYCLING YOU WANT ANY PL
SYSTEM. ADVOCATE SEPARATE
CONTAINER DEPOSIT SYSTEM
BECAUSE I SYSTEMS COULD CHEAT
IN EXCESS OF NINETY PERCENT.
AND YOU HAVE A ANY PIAF BY CUTS
LIKE PROGRAM. OF AND THAT'S
SYSTEM THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AND
DON'T TABBY I DON'T REALLY
HAVE. A FIFTY PERCENT FUNDED
EPL CURBSIDE. MODEL WHEN
THEY'RE LOOKING TO HIT. THE 70%
WITH A PACKING RIGHT. THEY SEE
THAT ALREADY WITH DEPOSITS CAN
I MEET AT HIGH LEVELS
RECYCLING. BUT THEY'VE MADE
THAT DECISION. TO GO THAT ROUTE
IT WASN'T IMPOSED UPON THEM
THEY JUST. THAT WAS WHAT THE
LEGISLATION ALSO OFFICE
VILLAGES IS A CIRCLE ECONOMY
EFFECT LEGISLATION IN ONTARIO
SO QUICKLY ME ACT REQUIRES THAT
THEY- ON TERRY HASTERT SAID BE
75% RECYCLING RIGHT. THE
POLICY'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
CONCEDE TO A EIGHTY ALL AT AS
MODELS ARE ONLY IT'S FIFTY
FIFTY. FUNDED BY HIS APOLOGIES
50% FUNDED BY THE INDUSTRY IT
IS MOVING TO A HOT AND FUNDED
WATER. AND OUT. ON THE SENATE
BY PRODUCES PRODUCES RIGHT OKAY.
I'M HOW DO YOU SEE THE CONVERSE
JUST THIS QUEST THE AUTHOR I
MEAN CONVERSATION MOVING. ON
THIS BILL WITH BEER AND WINE.
MY LOOK FOR TO THIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH BEER AND
WINE- NO I THINK. YOU KNOW THE
OR THE ORGAN FOR THE YOU KNOW
NOT WOOD ST WE HAVE WERE AGAIN
WINE INDUSTRY WANTS TO JOIN THE
PROGRAM SO IT AGAIN IT'S TWELVE
YEARS OF ITS MATURE BUT THEY
WANT TO GO IN ON THE PROGRAM AS
FAR AS THE WEIGHTS CONCERN. YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THIS IS PICKED UP
AT THE RESTAURANT IT'S PICKED
UP AT THAT YOU KNOW IT'S YOU
CAN YOU CAN SINGULARLY PROPERTY
AND- I'M- TOTALLY CONFIDENT
THAT THE- FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
CHALLENGE IS GOING TO BE WITH
WITH WEIGHT IT'S NOT A REASON
TO STOP ALL THE ALL THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'RE MAKING
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE WIND INDUSTRY THE DISTILLED
SPIRITS HAVE. OUT IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX CONGRATULATIONS
THAT'S THAT'S OKAY OUR HISTORY
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO THE
ORIGINAL PROGRAM WHAT HAVE OF
EVERYBODY ALL AND NOW WE'RE
SITTING TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
WE'RE ALL IN WORK WITH THEM ON
THE RE BOTTLE WHAT THE HELL
THEY WERE. INVOLVED IN ALL THAT
WILL FIGURE OUT PRIVATE
INDUSTRY WILL FIGURE OUT A WAY
THAT THIS CAN WORK BECAUSE AS
WE'VE HEARD FROM ONE OF THE
FULLER WANT TO HAVE THIS KATIE
WHERE WE WANT TO THE CIRCLE ON
ME AND RECYCLING IN. ALL ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE COUNTRIES
EVERY JURISDICTION UP WITH THAT
HOW WE GET END OF LIFE PROGRAMS
WITH A BOTTLE BECAUSE BOTTLES
AND CANS AND PLASTIC SWORDS AT
LEAST IN THE CONSTRUED PART
SIMPLEST THING AND THERE'S
MONEY THERE RIGHT SAY ONE THING
ALL THE WAY BACK SO. I'M WAIT I
KNOW IN OTHERS TO HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION IS IN THAT. BUT
HE'S HOLDING. OFF TO BE
INTRODUCED THIS DEPOSIT SYSTEMS
AND I STATES BECAUSE GLOSS HAS
THAT SHE KNOWS VALUE AND IS
COLLECTED FOR CUTS LIKE
COLLECTION PROCESS AND MOST
MOST MUNICIPALITIES A HAVING TO
HIGH GLOSS COLLECTED FOOD
DEPOSITS IS A BREAK SINCE
CONTAMINATE THE BASIC
CONTAMINATED GETS MIXED
ECONOMIC HYPOXIA SO I SHOULD
THE ARGUMENT OTHER STATES WAS
SAYING IS PLEASE INTO CHIU
SMOKE OFTEN PART OF THAT SYSTEM
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT AND I
CUTLASSES RAISE IT HAS NO VALUE
IS PAYING A COST ON TO ACT LIKE
SINCE. RIGHT THERE. HI I TAUGHT
IT FOR THE FULL TIME FOR THAT
TO. YOUR YEAH SENATE YEAH. SO
HEARING WE LIKE THE VENDOR.
DEPOSIT SYSTEM OR THE VENDING
MACHINE DEPOSIT SYSTEM I AM IN
OREGON- BC WALK TAKE ME BACK
THROUGH IT SO WHAT WHAT DOES
THE FUTURE LOOK LIKE I SHARE A
BOTTLE OF WINE DRINK IT IT'S
EMPTY I DON'T PUT IT IN THE BIN
AND CURBSIDE I TAKE IT TO YOU
HAVE A VENDING MACHINE AND POP
IT IN THE- VAN MáS ME BACK.
THE TODAY YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DO WHAT. HE WOULD. BECAUSE
LIKE. TIED UP BUT IN YOUR CASE
IF YOU WANTED TO PUT IT BACK
TAKE IT TO A RETAIL STORE TO AN
IBM TO GET YOUR CAR SO I GOT A
LIGHT BUT I GOTTA GET MY CAR
AND DRIVE IT SOME WHERE YOU
ONLY WHO'S GOT THE SUPERMARKET
I YOU KNOW. NO I'M NOT YOU
DON'T SHOW NO I'M GOING NO I'M
USING THE INTERNET OKAY I GO TO
COURT AND THAT'LL ANYWAY I'M
SORRY YEAH YES I KNOW YOU KNOW
MAYBE. A BUSINESS SET UP.
COLLECT PEOPLE'S ON THEIR. ON
MY ON LINE YOU KNOW. THE A
PROGRAMS ONLINE AND- SILOS
DISPUTED IS. PRESENT A LITTLE
OUT OF HAVING TO COULD BE
CALLED. BIG CORPORATIONS THAT
PROGRAMS WHETHER THAT'S WHETHER
THEY CUT HIS MATERIALS. I'M
FROM YOUR HOME OR WHERE THEY
SAT UPON THE SHIPS WHERE YOU
CAN TAKE THOSE CONTAINERS BACK.
FOR THAT PROGRAM SO. ONLINE
SALAS IS BECOMING. INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT PART FOR YOU DO YOU
SEE A LOT OF MILLENNIALS I GO I
WENT. OVER AND YOU SEE PEOPLE.
SHOWING UP WITH THE AND THAT'S
LIKE TO. COLLECT BLESSED IN THE
IN THE GARAGE IN THE- ONCE
EVERY TWO WEEKS WILL SHOW UP IN
THE DITCH POPULOUS OF IN THE
NIGHT YEAH. THE A TWENTY BUCKS
OR WHAT YOU KNOW AND THEN IT.
JUST ADDS. TO ALL PUBLIC. DOES
COST YES I'M. LOOK AT THE- AGE
TO. SEE WHAT. FOR SO THAT'S- I
DON'T. PEOPLE CYCLE. ALL OF THE
WORLD THAT IS. THEY DO IT EVEN
IF THEY GET THEIR FOOD DELIVER
TO THEM. AT THEIR AT THEIR
HOUSE SO WE'RE SAYING. STEP
BACK THIS COOPERATIVE THAT
WE'RE SETTING UP IN CALIFORNIA
IS GOING TO RUN IT THE WAY THAT
THEY WANT TO RUN IT THEY CAN
USE CURBSIDE THEY CAN USE
EXISTING FACILITIES I JUST SAID
AS AN AS AN OFFER OF EXAMPLE
SURE COOPERATIVE IN OREGON BY
ALL THEIR PROPERTIES THEY THEY
BY OTHER PROPERTIES THEY CALL
LOCATE SOME OF THESE THINGS ON
EXISTING. I'D SAY THEY DON'T
WANT TO RURAL AREAS AND COAL
OKAY THEY THEY THEY DO WHATEVER
THEY WANT THEY HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT. SO THE- INNOVATIONS THAT
ARE OCCURRING AROUND THE WORLD
ARE THESE REVERSE VENDING
MACHINES BECAUSE YOU'RE SO
SIMPLE YOU JUST POP IN YOUR-
YOUR- YOUR- GLASS. YOUR GLASS
AND YOU GET IT- SOME PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW ANY COUNTED THAT THE
MACHINE WILL DO WHATEVER ONCE
AND IT'S GREEN AND IT'S CLEAR.
OTHERS THEY'VE GONE WITH THIS
GREEN BAG IN BLUE BACK PROGRAM
WERE ALLOWS MILLENNIALS ARE NOT
MILLENNIAL STE WE GET TO TAG
THEIR BAGS AND DROP IT OFF WHEN
THEY GO IN. AND THEY HAVE THEIR
DISTRIBUTORS ARE ON THE SAME
PAGE SINCE THEIR RIGHT PROGRAM
SO WHEN THEY'RE THEY'RE GUY
WE'LL SANTA. SIX CRAIG. BEER
AND WINE AND SPORTS DRINKS THEY
COME BACK OUT WITH WITH THEIR
THEIR EMPTIES THEIR EMPTY SAVE
GOT THAT THEY FIGURED IT OUT
AND IS WORKING FINE. IT'S FINE-
THAT THAT NOT OUR COOPERATIVE
WILL DO WHATEVER THEY WANT TO
DO WHICH EVER BEST FOR
CALIFORNIA I'M JUST OFFERING IS
AN EXAMPLE SURE. SO ANOTHER
WOULD MECHANICS WISE FOR THE
BILL I APOLOGIZE HAVE NOT READ
THE HUNDRED THIRTY THREE PAGES.
BUT YOUR MEN OF FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF COLLECTION PROCESSING
RECYCLING BUT YOU'RE MAKING A
POLICY DECISION ABOUT THE HOW
IT HOW THE FEES ARE GENERATE
THE ACTUAL ASSESSMENT PROCESS
THAT'S WHERE THE BILL IS SORT
OF STAYING WE'RE GONNA DO ANY
P. R. MODEL THAT PUSH IT ALL
UPSTREAM WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THAT COULD BE A CURBSIDE FUTURE
COULD BE A VENDING MACHINE
FUTURE COULD BE A BLUE BACK
RIGHT BUT- BUT THAT'S SORT OF
THE- POLICY CHOICE IN YEARS
YOU'RE SAYING. I'M AT LIKE A
STRIP. E. P. R. MODEL WHERE
YOU'RE ASSESSING IT ON WHOEVER
THE BEVERAGE- SORRY THE
EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY YEAH SO LIKE
YOU'RE PUSHING IT THE CONSUMERS
AND BEARING THAT COST IN YOUR
FRAMEWORK YOUR YOUR NOT LOOKING
FOR A SHARED OR A SPLIT EACH IS
SOLELY ON THE MY CENTER I THINK
PRODUCER OR THE DISTRIBUTOR
DISTRIBUTOR NINE SAYS SO THAT'S
THAT'S FIX THOUGH THAT'S NOT
FLEXIBLE RIGHT SO NINETY EIGHT
POINT SOMETHING OF THIS BILL IS
SIMPLY JUST GETTING GETTING
RATED THE CODE. THAT HAS GOT IS
A PRODUCT OF THE ORIGINAL ACT
AND SEVENTY FIVE OTHER BILLS
JUST DELETE DELETE DELETE
DELETE OKAY SO THIS BILL IN
CONCEPT IS ELEGANTLY SIMPLE
BECAUSE IT GIVES THE ULTIMATE
FLEXIBILITY TO THIS PROPERTY WE
JUST SAID HERE SOME TIME LINE.
YOU KNOW THIS YEAR'S GET AGAIN
TO DO THIS AND THAT ALL SUBJECT
TO YOU KNOW TO CHANGE WITH THIS
IS OUR BEST OUR BEST EFFORT
THAT WE THAT WE HAVE. DID TWO
YEARS AGO AND SB ONE SIX EIGHT.
I THINK FROM CONCEPT WEVE GOT
THE BENEFIT OF HAVING TO YEARS
OF THE SUCCESS OF THE REACH OF
REUSABLE BOTTLES IN OREGON THEY
EXPANSION OF THE DROP CENTERS
AND SAYING OKAY AND THEN. WE
SAW IS THE WIDTH OF NICKEL TO
DINE. BLOOM 6035% INCREASE IN
THE IN THE USE PEOPLE OF PEOPLE
ARE USING IT SO PRICE DOES
MATTER SO THAT WE'VE TRIED TO
BE YOU KNOW. AS MUCH AS HANDS
OFFICE OF PUBLIC HEALTH PEOPLE
MADE SURE ALL HIS AND LET THESE
PEOPLE RUN THE PROGRAM OKAY SO.
THE ONE OTHER QUESTION I HAD
WAS. WE TRY TO SOLVE THE-
RECYCLING PROBLEM OR THE- FOR
THE FOR THE PLASTICS PROBLEM
THE SINGLE USE PLASTICS FROM OR
DO YOU THINK THE BILL CAN SOLVE
POST ALL OF ALL DO YOU EXPLAIN
THE SINGLE USE PLASTIC SIDE OF
IT BECAUSE I WE KNOW IT THAT'S
IT THIS IS JUST A BOTTLED
DOESN'T NOT TO SING A LOOSE IS
PRACTICE SIX I'M SORRY I MISSED
RIGHT WE CHOSE TRY TAKE THE
BROKEN BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM
WHICH- EVERYBODY AGREES. TO
PULL OPPOSE A GREASE IS THE
SYSTEM IS BROKEN AND SAYING
HERE'S A DIFFERENT SYSTEM THAT
WE'RE GONNA GO THAT'S THAT'S
ACHIEVABLE IN CALIFORNIA DINNER
SO NOT OVER PROMISE PRINTED IN
IN STERN OVER PROMISING WHAT
THE BCS SO IN THE COOPS DO WILL
NOT REALLY ADDRESS. JUST THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF NON RECYCLABLE
MATERIAL AND READ THE MATERIAL
YOU WON'T REALLY. NOT GOING TO
GO TO THIS. VENDING MACHINE IN
THE FUTURE AND THROW IN THE
PLASTIC WATER BOTTLE UNLESS
THERE'S A- UNLESS THERE'S A
MARKET FOR IT WELL WELL WELL
REMEMBER THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SET THE BECAUSE
EVERYBODY CHAU EVERY
DISTRIBUTOR SETS THE PRICE SO
LET'S JUST SAY YOU HAVE. ECO
FRIENDLY CAN COMPANY THAT MAKES
RANKS AND THEY SAY WE'RE AND
WE'RE GOING TO PAY WHATEVER THE
FEE IS AND WILL MAKE UP A WE
PARTICIPATE WERE ALL IN. YOU
GOT NON ECO FRIENDLY YOU KNOW
BOTTLE WITH TEN AND CLASSIC IN
THEIR PACKAGING IS ALL. THAT
PRIVATE INDUSTRY IS ABLE TO SET
THE PRICE ON WHAT IT IS IF YOU
WANT TO BRING THAT PRODUCT IN
THE CALIFORNIA. IT'S GONNA COST
YEAH YOU CAN BRING IN MORE
DETAIL BUT YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
GONNA COME UP THESE EXOTIC
PACKAGING IDEAS YOU'RE GONNA
PAY AND THAT'S PRIVATE INDUSTRY
ANOTHER PRIVATE INDUSTRIES.
THAT ASSESSMENT STILL GOES TO
AT DISTRIBUTOR RIGHT. RIGHT
YEAH A PLASTIC DISTRIBUTOR A
MIXED MATERIAL DISTRIBUTOR AND
THEY AND THEY EXTENDED TO THE
MANUFACTURER BECAUSE THE
BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA COULD GO
THE MANUFACTURES GETS ITS-
FACTORED ALL OF THE WORLD BUT
IF SOMEBODY IS GOING TO BRING
IN. A PRODUCT IT'S GOT ONE OF
THESE GOOFY SOME MARKETING
PERSON ON STEROIDS COME UP WITH
THEM THE MIX PACKAGE AND ALL
THIS STUFF THAT THEY THINK IS.
COOL. OKAY BUT YOU GET. IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE HOPE IS AT
THAT THEY SEE THE LIGHT AND
SAYING MAYBE WE'LL JUST GO WITH
A CLEAR BOTTLE MAYBE WE'LL GO
WITH SOMETHING THAT THAT. THAT
FIFTEEN THAT THE EXIT OF THESE
EXOTIC PACKAGING TYPES WE'RE
GONNA GO WITH SOMETHING THAT'S
THAT'S- THAT'S RE USABLE A FITS
INTO THE SPIRIT OF SB FIFTY
FOUR. AND IT'S NOT THAT SINGLE
USE PLASTIC IT'S NOT THAT WAY
IT'S NOT A DIRECT. IT IS.
ARTICULATED CONCERN BUT IT'S
ALL ABOUT PRICE THAT'S A GREAT.
GOOD THING THIS REPORTS SHOW
THAT WHEN THAT'S NOT DENNIS
DENNIS WANTS TO ALSO ADD ON
TIME. YEAH BUT. THIS IS WHAT I
GOTTA GO THIS IS NO. WAY I WILL
LET MISTER LOW FOR WHAT WENT
USED. RIVERS I'M SORRY WAS HERE
EARLIER IS IN ANOTHER HEARING-
I WANTED ANSWERS IF I COULD
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS OF US
FIRST OF ALL. ORGAN STARTED
FROM THE START THE NEW YEAR
REPRESENTING OUR CALIFORNIA
BEER BEVERAGE SENATORS. AND
ORGAN STARTED FROM THE START
THE DISTRIBUTOR STARTED SHORT
WERE NOW. WITH SOME TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY YEARS INTO THIS
PROGRAM AND WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO REBUILD IT AND RECAST AGAIN
BY SAYING WILL YOU
DISTRIBUTORSHIP. THIS FRANKLY
WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE RUN OF THE
FINANCING AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
CONTROL OVER WITH WHAT. THE
MANUFACTURER FOR BEER
DISTRIBUTORS WHAT HOW THEY
SELECT THEIR THEIR PACKAGING.
OF YOU KNOW WE DON'T. WE DON'T
DISTRIBUTE FOR THE MOST PART
OTHER OTHER PRODUCTS OTHER THAN
THAN BEER. AND BEVERAGES AND
SOME NEW AGE BEVERAGES BUT BUT
ALL OF THOSE THREE THEIR CANDOR
BOTTLED. WE DON'T HAVE CONTROL
OVER IT FOR A FOR LEX TO HAVE
ONE SIZE BOTTLE OR- WHATEVER
THEY DO. I THINK THAT THAT TO
SAY THE WITH THAT. OF A-
POPULATION OF FORTY MILLION CAN
CAN MOVE TO OREGON DID. WHICH
IS A MIX OF OUR POPULATION LESS
MILLION IN AND IN. TEN MONTHS
IS NOT REALISTIC OR POSSIBLE
AND THE BUILDER EVEN IF IT
TAKES EFFECT NEXT YEAR IT'S AN
OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SO WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THAT THERE'S- FIRST FALL ANY
REAL REASONABLE WAY TO EXPECT
EVER TO HAVE THE DISTRIBUTORS
BECOME. DISORGANIZATION AND
SPEND. YOU KNOW SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE HIS DREAM FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS TO DO THIS SO I'M
AND WE FRANKLY. DISAGREE AND WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES OR THE ABILITY TO DO
IT AND WE DON'T CERTAINLY DON'T
HAVE CONTROL OVER THE PACKAGING
THAT IS BEING DEVELOPED. PLUS
ARM OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH
THE EXISTING LAW. THAT WE HAVE.
PACKAGING THAT IS COMING FROM
OTHER STATES THAT THE MONEY WAS
NEVER RECEIVED HERE AND THAT'S
AND THAT'S MORE IMPORTANT. N
FORCE A LAW YOU'D YOU'D HAVE A
LOT BETTER PACKAGING THERE OR
CONTROLLED IN WHAT WE DO NOW
BUT BUT FRANKLY IT'S IT. IS NOT
ENFORCEABLE. OKAY THAT'S YOUR
FOR MISTER QUINN AND I JUST WAS
IN A DOLLAR FOR THE SENATE
RIGHT HILL AND SENATOR STERN IS
GONNA GET AYE I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT. WE FEEL THAT THE
CENTRAL CONCEPT OF THIS BILL.
IS RIGHT THAT BEVERAGE
COMPANIES HAVE TO TAKE
RESPONSIBLE. THE PRODUCTS WE
THINK COMPANIES YOU MEAN
DISTRIBUTORS THIS PRODUCERS.
THE PRODUCERS YEAH I MEAN YOU
KNOW PEOPLE CAN REALLY
DIFFERENT A- WELL IN THE BILL
IF YOU USE A RAP OR PRODUCT TO
SELL A PRODUCT YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR BASICALLY
MAKING SURE IT'S RECYCLED. AND
THE POINT IS THAT IF WE GO WITH
THE CONCEPT THAT MAKES THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROFITING. FROM
THE SALE OF- THE PRODUCTS IN
THOSE IN THOSE IN THOSE
BEVERAGES. BE RESPONSIBLE WE
CAN GET A REDEMPTION RATE
THAT'S 98% BECAUSE THEY DID IN
GERMANY OR 89% BECAUSE THEY'RE
DOING IT IN AN ARGUMENT
MICHIGAN AND- ALL THE DETAILS
THAT ARE GOING THAT WE TALK
ABOUT NOW I REALLY JUST WANT TO
REEMPHASIZE AS CONSUMER
WATCHDOG IS A CONSUMER GROUP
WERE ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE THEIR
MONEY. BUT A LOT OF THESE
DETAILS I DO THINK HAVE TO BE
WORKED OUT AS WE GO FORWARD IN
THE PROCESS BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
A SIMPLE PROGRAM AND I KNOW
THERE'S THE YOU HAVE YOUR DUE
DILIGENCE OBLIGATION A BUT WHAT
I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY THE
SENATOR STERN. IS THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT GETTING MONEY BACK
TO THE CONSUMER AND THERE IS A
SINGLE USE PLASTIC BILL THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL BE COMPATIBLE
WITH THIS BUT THERE'S OTHER
REFORMS THAT HAVE TO HAPPEN
WITH THIS BILL IS A MUCH AND
MAYBE MORE CONSUMER BILL AS IT
IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL BILL. SO
CRAFT. A SEND UP. THEY
RESEARCHED. SO THE NEW TO THIS
COMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY NOT NEW TO
THIS ISSUE I WANT TO PER SE TO
ALTER THIS BILL WHO HAS BEEN
DILIGENT IN FACT MY DAUGHTER
GOT A WHOLE EDUCATION THE OTHER
NIGHT WHEN MY OFFICE ABOUT
RECYCLING AND HOW ORGAN IS I
ACTUALLY FROM WHAT CASKEY NO
YEAH OKAY SHE SHE ASKED HIM
SOME GOOD QUESTIONS LIKE HOW
MANY JOBS ARE GONNA SUPPLY IN
HER DOWN. AND HE SAID HE DIDN'T
WILL GO OVER WELL. MAYBE ONE.
ANYWAY MY I REALLY HAVE MORE OF
A COMMENT THAN I DO THAT YEAH
THE END OF THE DAY- WE HAVE A
PROBLEM CALIFORNIA NO DOUBT
ABOUT RECYCLING IN THE MOUNT
RECYCLING AND WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH I MEAN I WAS ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WHEN THERE
WAS A 50% WE PUT ON OUR
LANDFILL WAS TWENTY YEARS AGO.
ALL RIGHT. AND WHAT WE HAVE IS
WE'VE HAD UPS AND DOWNS WE'VE
HAD MARKETS THAT HAVE. A LOT OF
THESE FOLKS THAT ARE IN THE
RECYCLING BUSINESS MADE A LOT
OF MONEY BECAUSE THERE WAS A
PLACE TO TAKE THIS PRODUCT AND
WHEN THEY'RE NOT A PLACE TO
TAKE THE PRODUCT. IT'S A
PROBLEM OF WHERE TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY FIRST OF ALL. THIS
BILL IS NOT A WORKING MODEL.
THAT'S A GREAT PRESENTATION
WAS OFF FOR. THIRTY FIVE
MINUTES. BUT YOU'RE BASICALLY
SAYING HEY SO DO THIS NOW. TO
THE DISTRIBUTOR BASICALLY YOU
PACKAGE OF HOW THEY'RE GONNA
THEY'RE GONNA FIGURE THIS OUT I
WILL SAY WE HAVE A BROKEN
CALORIE CYCLE SYSTEM WE HAVE
FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OUT
THERE REGULATING AND- THEN THEY
WERE MAKING THE MONEY OFF OF
WHAT WASN'T. RECYCLED. AND THE
CONSUMER PACE SO FOR ME MISTER
CHAIRMAN ASK A QUESTION OF YOU.
HAS THERE EVER BEEN. A TIME
WHERE WE SAT DOWN WITH THE-
DISTRIBUTORS THE RETAILERS. THE
RECYCLERS AND HAD A
CONVERSATION OF WHERE WE GO IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THIS BECAUSE I
WILL TELL YOU. THEY ONE GUY HAS
AN ISSUE THE- THE LITTLE MARKET
THAT I HAVE IT IN MY LITTLE
TOWN THAT I HAVE DOESN'T HAVE
THE- WHEREVER THEY'RE NOT. THE
SAFE WAY THEY'RE NOT COSTCO
DATE THEY ARE AN INDEPENDENT
OWNER OF THE STORE IT IS GOING
TO BE REQUIRED TO DO SOMETHING
AND WE WENT THROUGH I GOT LOTS
OF CALLS AND IN MY OFFICE WHEN
THEY HAD NO PLACE TO TAKE THEIR
PRODUCT AND THEN THEY WERE TOLD
THEY YOU YOU'RE TAKING BACK
HERE THERE'S CONTAMINATION
ISSUES ALL KINDS PROP AS EVER
BENNET A HEARING WHERE YOU SAT
DOWN WITH ALL THOSE FOR THE DAY
WELL AND SAID. HEY WE'RE GONNA
DO A BILL. WE DID THIS. WITH
HELP. AND YOU WILL NEED TO BE
THE TABLE YOU KNOW THE DAY OF
YOUR PART BE THE ONE TO LOSE MY
SO. YEAH HAPPENED MY ANSWER
THAT IS THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE CONTEXT OF.
THE CONVERSATION OVER SB. AB
TEN EIGHTY. I WE'VE BEEN HAVING
INTENSE CONVERSATIONS WITH A
GLASS FOLKS TO DISTRIBUTORS THE
GROCERS. CONSUMER GROUPS-
CITIES. HI THE PRODUCERS
MANUFACTURERS AND- HAVE A
WORKING REALLY HARD TO GET A
DEAL TOGETHER. AND WE'RE WE'RE
COMING WE'RE VERY VERY CLOSE. I
THINK PART OF MY- YOU KNOW I
YEAH. I WAS REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY WHATEVER COMES
OUT OF THIS CONVERSATION THREE
SEVENTY TWO AND I THINK THAT
THE GOALS ARE ARE. IN CONGRESS
WITH WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO A
FIFTY FOUR IN TEN EIGHTY. BUT I
WAS I WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THERE'D BE
COMPLEMENT. ANY ODD SO AS TO
RESPECT ALL THOSE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING IN AND
ALL THAT STUFF HARD WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO. TRYING TO CROSS
SOMETHING IT REALLY DOES WORK
FOR EVERYBODY. WHICH IS WHICH
IS AT THE HEART OF A WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO A FIFTY FOUR. IN
TEN EIGHTY MISSED CHAIR AND
CENTER DOLLY GOVERNOR BROWN
CONVENE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS.
242-016-2016 TO AND THIS
COMMITTEE WHEN I CHAIRED IF WE
HADN'T OVERSEE. EVERYBODY TO
TRY TO. PICK WHAT WITH WHAT
WITH THE PROBLEMS RESULT OF
THAT IN. TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN
WAS IT. ONE STATE WHICH BOOKS.
I HAVE AN EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSE BILLION ST GOT. YOUR
HEARING UP ABOUT THE PEOPLE ARE
SAYING WE'RE NOT COLLECTING
THIS THEY'RE NOT COLLECTING OR
THROUGH WE'RE GETTING 50% THE
PRICE AND ALL THE PROBLEMS THAT
ARE WRONG WITH IT RIGHT NOW AND
DOZENS AND DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
BILLS. THAT ARE GETTING. GET
INTRODUCED AND HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED TO PUT BANDAIDS ON%
TO SAY GIVE THIS GUY MORE MONEY
GIVE THIS GUY MORE MONEY GIVE
HER MORE MONEY GIVE HER MONEY
EVERYBODY WANTS TO GET MORE
MONEY. FROM CAL RECYCLE THIS IS
ELEGANTLY TAKING A STEP BACK
AND SAYING THE BIG PICTURE
YOU'RE RIGHT I'M NOT I'M I
DON'T GET TO TELL ANYBODY ANY
COOPERATIVE HOW TO GET AROUND
THIS PROGRAM. I JUST OFFER
WORKING PROGRAM SAYING THIS IS
WHAT THEY'RE DOING WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A CALIFORNIA PROGRAM
THAT'S GOOD LOOK MAKING
CALIFORNIA FOR CALIFORNIANS
THAT'S GOING TO BE DEVELOPED.
WHEN THIS BILL GOES LIVE IT'S
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR JANUARY
TWENTY FOURTH IT'S FOUR YEARS
FROM NOW. YOU KNOW WHEN THEY
WHEN BASED ON THE BILL INTACT
AND I'M WILLING TO IF SOMEBODY
SAYS OH MY GOD FOUR YEARS IS
NOT ENOUGH. YOU FOLKS
CALIFORNIA CAN'T GET IT
TOGETHER THE REASON WE WERE
TRYING TO DO THIS. ONE THIS
RENDITION OF IT TO GIVE
EVERYBODY ALL THE TIME
EVERYBODY EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT
THIS. MY GOOD FRIENDS WHO SAID
WHAT ELSE HE'S BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS BEFORE YEARS I'M
STILL TALKING ABOUT IT. THE
ANSWER POLITICALLY DO WE HAVE
THE STRENGTH TO COME TOGETHER.
PUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
CONSERVATIVES AND LIBERALS IN
STATE THIS IS THE BEST WAY THIS
IS THE PATH WE LET PRIVATE
INDUSTRY DO IT AND I AM OPEN I
HAVE BEEN OPEN. YOU KNOW UP TO
THE DEATH CONVERSATION BUT
I'VE- WILL BE KEPT IT. SIMPLE
AND LET THESE GUYS RUN THE
PROGRAM WERE GALS. GUYS GALS.
YEAH WELL I WAS. I'M NOT I'M
NOT CONVINCED THAT WE'VE LOST
OUT ALL OF THE. RECYCLING
LOOPHOLES AND I AND TO. WE MEET
IN IN. I GUESS MY POINT IS THAT
I WASN'T PART OF ANY THOSE I
WAS I'VE ALWAYS ON YOU Q. AND-
IN THE OTHER HOUSE. MOST OF THE
TIME I'VE BEEN IN THIS
LEGISLATURE I HAVE BEEN A PART
AYE. WHERE OF THE- ONE OFFICE
AND THE- CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
BEEN FACED WITH. IN RECYCLING
WHETHER IT'S- RECYCLING. YOU
KNOW. SINGLE USE. ROOMING
NEEDLES FREEWARE IVAN ON TOURS.
WITH RICH GORDON WHEN WE HAD
ALL THOSE ISSUES- SO I'M NOT. A
100% CONVINCED THAT THIS IS I
I'M- EXCITED ABOUT HAVING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO.
WEIGH IN WITH. WITH ACTUALLY
THE STAKEHOLDERS AT THE TABLE.
SITTING DOWN SAYING. WE DID
THAT. WITH THAT ONE BONTA DID
SB IS IT IN OF AB SEVENTY TWO
WAS THE WAS THE- IT WAS A BILL
WHERE WE. TALK ABOUT HEALTHCARE
WE BASS HE SAID THE DOCKS IN
THE AND HELP TO BE WE'RE GOING
TO BILL WE HAVE A BIPARTISAN
BILL. WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
SAME COMMITMENT HERE THIS IS
WE'RE GOING TO DO SOMETHING TO
FIX THIS PROCESS. BUT EVERYBODY
HAS TO BE THE TABLE YOU CAN'T.
BECAUSE TRUST ME THE
DISTRIBUTOR. IS HEARING WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA GET IT NOW HE
SAID I CAN'T DO THAT WELL IF
YOU'RE- IF YOU HAS NOT BE SAY
THERE'S WHAT WE WILL DO. AND BY
THE WAY THE RETAILERS GONNA
HAVE THIS AND EVERYBODY'S IT.
EVERY DAY. AND THAT. COMES AYE
GUYS ARE TO. HE'S OUT RIGHT
NOW. AND THERE'S- AT THE END OF
THE DAY. WHEN THERE'S MONEY TO
BE MADE THEY'RE ALL HAPPY. BUT
WHEN THERE'S NO MONEY TO BE
MADE EVERYBODY BOARD TO PUSH
OFF ON SOME BILLS NATURAL ROUTE
RIGHT NOW. I WOULD JUST SAY THE
CAL RECYCLE IS ACTUALLY THE
PLACE WE'RE ALL THAT WAY. ALL
THAT HAPPENS ONE JUST SAY THE
WAY. THE REASON CAL RECYCLE
AGREE WITH YOU THAT COVER CYCLE
IS IT. IS IT IN YOUR AUCTION IS
MURATSUCHI AND THAT'S WHY OUR
RETENTION RATES FALL AND
HOPEFULLY. THEY CAN FIX SOME OF
IT BUT THE FACT IS. ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS. IN THAT PROCESS.
GETTING WHAT THEY WANT CALVET.
DESPITE ALL THE TIME PETER JIM
SO. I THINK I WELCOME THIS
TABLE TO TRY TO. LOOK BIG
PICTURE WITH ALL THOSE PEOPLE
AROUND. I JUST I'M SORRY TO
LEAVE TO GO VOTE. I AND MY
CONCERN IS. IS SIMILAR TO
DOLLIES AND IT'S RECOGNIZING
THE WORK THAT WE JUST PUT IN
FOR A WHOLE YEAR. RIGHT AND PUT
A PACKAGE TOGETHER THAT
ACTUALLY WOULD WORK FOR
EVERYBODY AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
SORT OF. BLUNTNESS AND JUST
COMING BACK WITH IT RIGHT IT'S
LIKE. BUT I. WE'RE PICKING AN
ASSESSMENT METHOD HERE AND
WE'RE SAYING THESE GUYS GOING
TO BEAR THE THEIR LOOK
DISTRIBUTOR STRAIGHT UP
MEANWHILE THE FRAMEWORK WE GOT
OUT THERE IS SAYING MAYBE IS A
MIX OF WAYS TO ASSESS THAT. AND
I GET THE FLEXIBILITY OF THE
BACK END MY CONCERN IS. ON THE
FRONT END I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
DARN CLOSE TO A DEAL ON A
BROADER CIRCULAR ECONOMY
FRAMEWORK AND WHILE THIS COULD
BE ONE METHOD THAT THEY USED TO
IMPLEMENT THAT. WERE PRE
DECIDING THAT. SURE AND- I
JUST. SUPPORT THE BILL AND I
APPRECIATE YOU PUT A TON OF
TIME TO THIS ISSUE BUT- I GUESS
STUDY A LITTLE MORE CLOSELY.
THE ACTUAL THE ASSESSMENT
METHOD RECOGNIZING THAT SORT OF
BOTH FRAMERS I GUESS ARE
FLEXIBLE A BIT ON THE BACK AND
RIGHT YOU'RE NOT PRESIDING
CURBSIDE VERSES THAT THAT'S
GOOD I LIKE THAT. BUT I BUT I
AM. I'M JUST CURIOUS OF WHAT
OTHER FRAMEWORKS ARE OUT THERE
ANY CORPORATE TO ME P. R.
PRINCIPLES BUT ARCHER TAILORED
TO OUR- GEE I CAN'T TAKE. ON
WE'LL BE ECONOMY AND SO. THAT'S
THE HEART I DON'T KNOW I'M JUST
I'M STILL STRUGGLE WITH THAT
BUT I. I LIKE THAT YOU'RE
WAITING IN WITH A WITH A- SORT
OF JUST. ONE STRAIGHT. LIKE
THIS IS THIS IS HOW YOU THINK
IT SHOULD BE DONE AND- I THINK
IT. BEARS WEIGHING IN THAT
CONVERSATION BUT WE'VE COME A
LONG WAYS AND WE'RE DARN CLOSE
SO I REALLY WANT TO LAND
SOMETHING SOON. SENATOR NIGHT.
YOU ARE HERE FOR MY OPENING
COMMENTS I'M A WATER FIFTH OF
SB FIFTY FOUR I'M I WILL STOP
THIS BILL IF SB FIFTY FOUR IN
AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR INCLUDED.
EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY AT THAT THE
FINAL LANGUAGE BECAUSE IT'S
FLOATING I'M HERE AS A I GUESS
YOU COULD SAY AS A BACKDROP IF
WE IF THINGS GO AND OR THERE IS
AMENDMENTS ARE MADE I'M LOOKING
AT JUST THE BOTTLE BILL. AT THE
BROKEN DOWN CAL RECYCLE SYSTEM
THE THAT EVERY YEAR AND I'M
SAYING IF JUST SEND THIS PIECE
NOT SINGLE USE AND NOT YOU KNOW
PUT PLASTIC. OUR MOTION WASTE
YEAH BUT THAT I'M TAKING THIS
ONE LITTLE PIECE AND SAYING.
DOESN'T WORK OUT. THEN I WANT
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS FOR YEARS AND
FOR YEARS BEFORE IT ACTUALLY
GOES LIFE POTENTIALLY. SO I AND
IF IT NEEDS TO BE SAID I WILL
SEE IT I SAY IT. I MY STAFF AND
I HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
OVER THE LAST YEAR WHY SB FIFTY
FOUR IS GOING FORWARD EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT WHITE HOUSE HE'S
GONNA COME BACK ANOTHER EPR
BILL WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
REPORTS THAT- MISTER COURTS-
TO. COME ARE OF- ORGANIZATION
AND THE GREEK GODDESS OF GOOD
GOVERNANCE IN KNOW ME I CAME
OUT WITH WE WAITED A YEAR FOR
THE VERY VERY AND SAID THIS
THING SO I KNOW I HAVEN'T TOLD
EVERYBODY YES BUT THIS IS THIS
IS WHY WE- WERE TO YOUR BILL
THIS GOT INTRODUCED TO. LAST
YEAR SO I GOTTA GO TODAY. AND I
WOULD URGE UNLESS ANYBODY HAS
OTHER QUESTIONS AND I VOTE AND
EMOTION. DID YOU EVER SERVE
QUICKLY DID AND THEN AND THEN
LET'S AND I LET'S. ENTER SENT
OKAY JUST THE VERY QUICKLY.
THANK YOU MISTER OUR FIRST OLD
BILL IS NOT A- OF WIND FOR
YEARS. IT'S REQUIRED THAT THE
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL BE DO DONE
BY OCTOBER FIRST. OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OF THE BILL TAKES.
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MY MAP THAT'S THAT'S TEN MONTHS
OR NINE MONTHS ACTUALLY BUT
THAT BUT BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
GONNA DO THE COUNCIL YOU ACT
AND IMPLEMENTED. YOU HAVE TO
REALLY KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THEN. YOU YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T
SAY WELL IN IN THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS ARE GOING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO KNOW. WHAT YOU'RE
DOING AT THAT POINT SO IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE. EVEN IF IT DOESN'T
TAKE AFFECT FOR THREE MORE
YEARS FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
YOU STILL GOING TO HAVE TO KNOW
WHAT THAT IS. AND THAT'S AND
THAT'S A NINE MONTH PROCESS SO
I DISAGREE WITH THE SENATOR ON
ON HIS MATH AND BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T. SAY WELL WE'RE GOING TO
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS IF YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR COST WHAT
YOUR- HOW YOU'RE GOING TO. DO
WHAT YOU'RE TO DO WITH THE
PRODUCT YEAH. ALL OF IT AND IT
WASN'T OKAY. AND SOME MEMBERS
AT I'M SORRY HORTON PRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA BE OUR BEVERAGES
TRIGGERS THERE SEEMS TO BE MASS
CONFUSION UPPER HERE BETWEEN
WHO WOULD DISTRIBUTOR IS IN WHO
A PRODUCER AS ALL THESE OTHER
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL ALL THE
ABOVE PRODUCERS MANUFACTURERS
WERE THE DISTRIBUTORS WE HAVE
NO ABSOLUTE NO CONTROL OVER THE
PACKAGING HOW IT'S REPROCESSED
WHAT IS DONE. MY PEOPLE PERFECT
AND WE BUSINESSES NOT FORTUNE
FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES LIKE IN
THE BUSH THE WINE INDUSTRY
OTHER PEOPLE WERE FAMILY
BUSINESSES UNDER THIS BILL IT
IS SO BAD AND I MEAN GO INTO
THIS WE'RE GOING TO TALK THIS
LATER SCOTT ME JUST SO FIRED UP
ABOUT IT. THEY BASICALLY WOULD
DO THAT THEY WOULD SAY IF YOU
DON'T PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
TAKE AWAY YOUR LICENSE TO
DISTRIBUTE IF YOU TAKE AWAY OUR
LICENSE WE LOSE OUR PRIMA'S BUT
THE BROUGH THE BREWERS AND WE
GO OUT OF BUSINESS WE'RE TIME
OUT THIRTEEN THOUSAND JOBS. FOR
PEOPLE FAMILY BUSINESS THEY
DON'T HAVE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
TEAMS TO GO SIT ON THE COUNCIL
INTO THIS ACTIVITY I GOT FAMILY
BUSINESS. THAT ARE DEALING WITH
ALL. ACCORDING ALL THESE OTHER
ISSUES AND THIS IS A PROBLEM
YOU'RE COMPARING US TO PORTLAND
I MEAN TO OREGON AND I KNOW MY
COUNTERPART UP THERE THEY
CREATED THAT PROGRAM THE DID
IT ALL THOSE MONIES CHEATED OUT
THERE'S NEVER BEEN IS CHEAP
THERE'S NO MONEY MAKING OFF OF
THIS IS GOING TO COST FOR
PEOPLE IT'S A TAX THIS IS A
DEEP DEEP PROBLEMS THEY'RE IN
THE WRONG PLACE IF THEY WANT
SOME SORT OF STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM LOOK TO THE
MANUFACTURERS FOR JUST SMALL
FAMILY BUSINESSES OUT HERE AND
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. HOW MANY
BILLIONS OF CONTAINERS WE'RE
TALK ABOUT PLASTIC WE HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH PLASTIC WERE
BASICALLY BEER YOU KNOW BEER
GLASS WERE BASICALLY ALUMINUM
WE DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO THIS
OUR PEOPLE RUN THOSE KIND OF
BUSINESSES THAT NOT WHAT WE DO
WE DO WAY OUT SPACE FOR TRUCKS
WHERE WE GO I DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO EXPECT IS DO OR HELP HANDLE
SO THE THAT OFF ON MY FAMILY
BUSINESS BARELY HAVE TIME TO
PERSIST BUT HARDLY ANY
ASSOCIATION BECAUSE THEY ARE
BUSY TRYING TO RUN THESE
BUSINESSES AND KEEP AFLOAT NOT
LOOSE BRANDS. NOT A IN A
THURMOND TAXPAYERS IS JUST ON
IN THAT PART WERE PROTESTING
WORSE THING THAT COMES WITH
THIS PROGRAM WE KNOW CHINA IS
NOT TAKING BACK RECYCLING WE
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON WITH A LOT
OF PROBLEMS EITHER BUT WE'RE
STILL AT. SEVENTY IT'S NOTHING
TO DO WITH THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU OKAY OKAY SO I'M
CLEARLY YOU'VE GOT SOME
CHALLENGES WITH DISTRIBUTORS-
THERE'S AN TIME FRAMES ISSUES
THAT I WOULD ASSUME YOU KNOW
YOU YOU MAY WANT TO SPEND
SOMETIME WORKING ON THIS
EMISSIONS WITH WINE AND IT WE
GOT IT WE GOT A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT THINGS GOING ON HERE.
I'M CERTAINLY YOU KNOW. VERY I
SHARED IN THE SMITH CENTER
STERN'S. CONCERNS. VETO ABOUT
ABOUT- BUT BUT ALSO PERHAPS
SOME COSTS OPTIMISM GIVEN WHAT
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO- TO MEET SOME OF THE KIND OF
CONCEPTUAL GOALS WITH HOW THIS
INTERPLAY'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO ON FIFTY FOUR TEN EIGHTY.
SO BUT YOU KNOW YOU MADE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT YOUR- YOU'RE
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR TO TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO. OUT WORKING
INTO WHAT IT WHAT WE'RE WORKING
ON AND TO. ENGAGE IN IN YOU
KNOW IN ROBUST DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE OPPOSITION- SO I YOU KNOW
AND I CERTAINLY SALUTE YOU FOR.
YOUR YOUR COMMITMENT TO. WHAT
IS AN ENORMOUS INFRASTRUCTURAL.
AND CONSUMER. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL- I'VE CHALLENGE
CLOCK CRISIS YOU KNOW WITH
REGARDS TO WASTE MANAGEMENT AND
OUR STATE AND I DO THINK
THERE'S A LOT WE CAN LEARN FROM
OTHER PLACES BUT I YOU KNOW
CLEARLY THERE'S STILL A LOT OF.
OF OUTSTANDING ISSUES NEED TO
BE- SORTED OUT WITH REGARDS TO
THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD SO- NO
BUT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING IN MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU IT'S
REALLY WE ARE COMMON EVEN
MAKING TODAY THAT. YOU'RE
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
AT THE- AND- THEN WHERE WOULD I
THINK EVERYONE IN THIS
COMMITTEES GIVEN HOW ENGAGE
WE'VE ALL BEEN ON THE- IN THE
BROADER. CIRCULAR ARMY PLAY-
VERY INTERESTED IN. IN IN IN
WATCHING IN HELPING AND IN YOU
KNOW CONTINUING ENGAGEMENT ON
ON HOW THIS HOW THIS WOULD
WOULD WOULD AFFORD IF IT WERE
TO COME OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
SO- YES ANAHIT AT THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE IN. AND I'LL POINT IN
THIS THIS HEARING ANY LONGER OR
ANY MORE THAN IT HAS BEEN BUT-
YOU KNOW I AM. I WILL MAKE A
MOTION- BUT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT. THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED AND I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THEM BUT I.
KNOW THE INTEGRATION BETWEEN
THE BILLS IN YOUR BILLS AS
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE I MEAN
WE HAVE TO SOLVE SOME OF THESE
PROBLEMS FOR THIS IS. IS A
SUCCESS. AND BUT WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING. AND NOT CAN'T IT
CANNOT IGNORE IT ANY LONGER. SO
I- I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
AS IS WILL IS THAT COMMITMENT
IS THERE THAT WE WILL. CONTINUE
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT I
JUST HEARD- SPECIALLY TO
DISTRIBUTE WE CAN'T KEEP
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE DO IN THE
BUILDING ALL THE TIME. SO I
JUST WE NEED TO. THAT AND I
HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO DO THAT SO HAVE BEEN
WITH THE BILL. OKAY I'M I'M SO
WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING I WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. TAKE A YOU
TAKE YOUR COMMENTS IS AS THE
CLOTHES. OKAY OKAY I'LL HAVE
OTHER REALLY DO APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PARTICIPATION I
THINK I THINK THE COMMITTEES
HEARD EVERYBODY'S PERSPECTIVES
AND YOU KNOW EVERYTHING I HEARD
TODAY. CONFORMS WITH VARIOUS
ASPECTS MY UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS VERY COMPLEX CHALLENGE OF
A SPECIAL COUNSEL WE'VE GOT TO
GET OUR HEADS AROUND AND- I
THINK THERE IS A- PATH. TERMS
COMPLEMENTARITY HERE IN
ADDRESSING ALL THE VARIOUS
CONCERNS THAT ARE OUT THERE
BUT- YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA TAKE A
LOT OF HARD WORK AND- WHAT A
LISTENING IN OPEN CONVERSATIONS
AND. ENOUGH ONES WHAT WE'VE AND
WHAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON ON
ON ON OUR SITE WITH OUR BILL SO.
TIME CERTAINLY DID AS FOR THE
BILL THEY WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING
AND AS OUR SECRETARY COLOR ALL.
I AM NUMBER ONE SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
WIECKOWSKI THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ALLEN
ALLEN AYE BATES DOLLY HELL.
HILL AYE SKINNER STERN STERN
IOWAY CASKEY MAKOWSKI AYE. OKAY
SO THAT DOES HAVE AN EFFORT TO
GET OUT THE WE WILL. START OKAY
SO WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN-
FOR LOVE IF TO LET CENTERS IS
GONNA SKINNER IN THE BILL. AND
BATES THEN I OKAY BUT SKINNER
HERE. YEAH THE OTHER STUFF
SENATE DOLLY- AND LET'S OPEN UP
THE ROLE- ONE MORE TIME FOR SB
THREE SEVEN TWO SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI THE IT. CHAIR VOTED I
AM. FOUR ZERO BATES DOLLY NO
VALLEY NO SKINNER. OKAY SO
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE IT OPEN FOR A
LITTLE LONGER FOR CENTER
SKINNER DATA
. HEARD FROM THE
PROVERBIAL GRAPEVINE THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE CENTERED SKINNER IS
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO MAKE IT SO
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING. WE HAVE A FOUR
TO ONE VOTE TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS IT'S GOING TO GO OVER THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SO WE WILL NOW CLOSE
THE ROLE ON SB THREE SEVEN TWO.
AND CALL THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE YOU COMMITTEE ADJOURNED